Did Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy from it.
Do you hear that?
Lighter bitches.
Sandra does.
Client of background.
All right,
respect.
Um,
and it's also a loophole,
Joe.
It's a loophole Brown.
Yeah,
because that means I can also use a lighter,
right?
Oh yeah,
you can loophole.
You can smoke while dices here.
Yes.
Normally I flip it and look at my life.
Your life as a man's line.
That's a Zippo.
That's how you do it.
That's real.
That's legit.
That's like,
it's an HBO special type Shit.
We're also brought to you by Onnit,
a makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
all different nootropics.
Uh,
Google it.
If you're interested in it,
don't just go by and stuff.
And if you're a,
if you're interested in nutrition,
you should really look into multivitamins and looking to eat in a clean diet and
keeping your body healthy.
But if you want to keep your,
your dome healthy nootropics are the way to go.
There's a couple different supplements that I liked it,
I don't even sell.
There's a thing called neuro one that this Guy Bill Roman ask,
he was a pro football player.
He puts out and that's how I got into nootropics in the first place,
so I always give respect to Mr. Roman house key and his product and what Alpha
brain is.
It's the Basque cognitive vitamins that you can buy all meshed up together and a
very potent form.
If you try it and you do not like it,
the first 30 pills you buy,
you get 100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
Just stay this stuff.
Socks,
I don't want,
I just want my money back and we give it to you.
We're much more concerned with you not feeling being ripped off than we are with
Megan money.
I want to make sure that if we're selling anything,
it's the best shit we can sell and it's only shit that I use,
so check it out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t and entering the code name,
Rogan.
And you'll save 10% off any and all orders.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Andrew motherfucking dice clay is in the house.
Respect.
Cue The music.
Brian.
Well,
good experience.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Stop official to the music begins.
I liked the music.
Thank you sir.
Andrew dice clay and his son Max is here as well.
It's happening.
And I'm Andrew.
When uh,
I was a kid,
man when I was like 19 years old.
I had this girlfriend,
this hot,
dirty little Latina girl that I dated for awhile and she fucking loved your
comedy.
We would sit in my car and we would play your cassette and this chick would
fucking how she would cry and curl up in a ball.
And I remember being a teenager,
a kid,
you know,
sitting there listening to how fucking funny this stuff was and how dirty and
different than anything there was ever be.
You had broken a total new barrier for comedy to me when I was a kid.
There was never a comedian like you before.
There was like that had this sort of like really aggressive sort of attitude
about it and it was,
it was,
it was fun and it was like you could repeat the shit with you.
It was a weird phenomenon man.
So for me to go from like listening to your stuff,
you know,
before I even got into an open mic and then being able to hang out with you at
the store and getting advice from you at the store,
you're the first guy that ever told me to go on the road.
Well you know what that because it was sort of driving me a little nuts with you
because you were a new guy at the store and you know you had a big career.
We're ready.
I mean,
I dunno what people listening to this know of your whole Korea,
but you had a hit sitcom on at the time.
This is before fear factor.
It wasn't really a hit.
It wasn't when it hit,
when it got off the air,
but sort of we can't put,
it was on for five years and I would like,
why isn't this guy on the road?
Like it would bother me.
I always liked,
you know,
comics that were into their careers and obviously you were and you know,
I saw you on stage doing your thing and I'm like,
why isn't this guy on the road?
I mean that's what this is all about.
You know?
And I saw that you loved,
you know,
after seeing like one,
three hour set,
you know that you did.
I'm going,
obviously he likes being up there,
but why be up there for $25 for three hours when you could be on the road making
all this money.
I remember the conversation and the outback back near that wall and I was like,
you got to go on the road now.
It's that moment,
you know?
And because even though you know I love what I do,
I also think business wise and when I started out and when I saw how,
you know to me how boring comics want,
you're not one of them obviously,
you know,
but no matter how funny they were,
I would also get like bored with them after like five or six minutes because
they knew nothing about performance.
And that's even how the whole dice thing started because I decided if I'm going
to stay in comedy,
got my aim was never even comedy.
I couldn't give a fuck about comics or comedy.
I use the comedy stage cause I want them to get into acting.
And when I decided,
okay,
I'm going to do this because I had a different act way before you knew me,
I would do like impressions of Travolta.
He used to close with a dice man.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
no.
What happened is my initial act was coming on stage as Jerry Lewis is nutty
professor,
you know,
with the glasses and actually lanes from Chapman and doing all that shit.
And I would take my magic potion and I would turn into John Travolta from Greece
because Travolta at the time I started my ACC was the biggest thing in the
world,
cause he had Saturday night fever and he did Greece.
And when I saw grease,
I,
me and Travolta could've been brothers back then when I was like 17.
So when I saw grease,
I was like,
if I could sing and dance like this guy,
I could put together this act that just
won't miss.
And so I went to a studio in Brooklyn,
took the album from Greece,
they took the lead vocal at of grease lightning.
And I started doing this act.
I mean,
the first time I went up and pip some Brooklyn on audition night,
um,
you know,
I came up as Jerry Lewis and it's a Brooklyn crowd,
and I'm up there with a giant Tuxedo shirt covering the leather and my pants are
rolled up under the Tuxedo shirt.
And I'm onstage calling.
Actually,
I'm the Human Petty Ladies and Gentlemen,
and you know,
it's a Brooklyn audience and that my whole family is there,
you know,
and everybody's yelling,
get the fuck off you fucking sock.
Fuck you scumbag.
You know?
And now I take the magic potion and they shut the lights and they turn like you
did the music arm,
which was my intro.
And I turned around as Travolta from Greece and the place when fucking insane.
And now I come up to the mic because it was like the potion could turn you into
that kind of Wa as Jerry Lewis.
I would go half this,
Polish them,
ladies and gentlemen as the throwing shit at me.
[inaudible] to that kind of match on Mantilla foxy woman up both,
you know.
So I take the potion and I turned into Travolta,
they go nuts.
I come up to the mic and I go to,
so you thought it couldn't be done right?
And they go crazy.
Now I do the grease lightning number.
So you're dancing and everything.
Oh,
I do,
I do.
The whole thing choreographed I work is music plans,
the whole grease number.
Um,
with a dance in the middle that I had cut in between fever and grease and the
place goes nuts.
And on the way out the to own is Marty and says,
Schulz,
go wait a minute,
where you go in,
because they wrecked the club,
they started throwing tables over cause something to doing jokes is Travolta
like,
so Mr [inaudible] system goes,
Vinny,
did you do your homework?
What I was doing that whole Barbarino thing,
you know,
so he was so hot at the time,
Travolta and there was such a resemblance and the impression was so dead on.
They go,
we want you to headline this weekend.
And they go,
who's your manager?
And I go,
uh,
and I look at my dad,
I go,
he is now going,
well it's only $50,
but you know,
he gets to headline and I'm like,
great.
We couldn't even fucking believe what happened.
So when I came out to the comedy store,
you know Mitchell Walters?
Yeah,
I know he,
okay.
So Mitchell Walters was a comedy store comic who's from Brooklyn.
So he was back in Brooklyn like about four months into my career.
When he saw me on stage and he goes over to my father and he goes,
he's got to come out to La to do the comedy store.
And I'm like,
you know,
I wasn't even into comedy.
I couldn't care less,
you know.
And he kept calling.
He goes,
I spoke to Mitzi,
the owner,
the comedy store,
she psych from to come out there.
So
I come out and I do the act.
They do a 28 minute audition on a,
you know,
the Monday night,
whatever it was,
where,
you know,
the emcee starts screaming at me when I come off stage.
Uh,
this guy,
uh,
what was his name?
Rob Guajillo.
And,
uh,
and I'm looking at the guy and I go,
are you to manage it?
You know,
a No.
I go,
are you the owner here?
And he goes,
no.
And I go,
then why are we even talking?
I go,
I didn't come,
you know,
across the country to do three minutes.
And of course,
Mitzi,
then I got the call,
I was in,
you know,
and you know,
I did,
I said,
you been on stage total at that point.
You know what,
I was in the business for about six months,
but from the night I went on stage at pips,
I never came off.
Wow.
Because I was totally driven to become this humongous store,
whether it's a movie star or get my own show.
And so when Mitzi met me,
she goes,
you're an absolute movie star,
you know,
I,
I had more hair back then,
you know.
But um,
she goes,
you're going to stay here and your hone your craft.
The whole thing,
just like you know about.
And actually I took that Travolta direct all the way to Don Kirshner is rock
concert and after Kirsten has rock concert,
I was like,
well,
movie producers aren't going to buy me to be Jerry Lewis or John Travolta.
I got to be myself on stage.
And that's where the whole dice type of character started.
And when Mitzi sword for the first time,
it was so great.
She goes,
it's never going to work.
it's too tough.
It's angry,
it's tough.
So I told her,
just keep me at the Westwood comedy store.
I go,
don't worry about it.
And when she said that I knew how wrong she was and I just went to work on,
you know,
Westwood was where she would put all the newer guys like myself and Kennison and
Roseanne,
people like that,
that wouldn't know like the sunset part of town was that,
that was in Westwood right off,
right on Westwood Blvd.
And um,
that's where I got to see like this first,
uh,
this guy stabbed the guy in the alley there.
They had to stop a knife fight.
Oh,
it was nuts.
Disguise.
Just stabbing a guys like Dan,
like,
like this,
I'm going,
what the,
I had run into the comedy store and get a stool to hit them.
Wow.
You know,
because I'm not going to get stabbed,
but I wanted to save the guy without the knife,
you know,
Christ.
And,
uh,
so I stayed at Westwood and I developed the character and you know,
the rest became history because what I was true,
I'm going the long way.
But when I would see the comics,
that was my whole point on stage,
whether it was,
you know,
Leno were Richard Lewis.
So you know,
these were to clean a guy's,
but they would bore me if the like five or six minutes I go that funny.
But yeah,
that boring.
They don't perform.
It does no danger in it.
Well,
I decided I'm going to become the most exciting stand up ever in history.
If I'm going to do this,
I want to get people something they never saw with a comedian.
And growing up,
like I said,
I didn't really study comics.
I studied big personalities,
whether it be Elvis,
whether it was Muhammad Ali in movies.
It was everybody from Stallone to Travolta too when I was a kid,
James Dean and Brando.
And I said,
give them that.
I'm from Brooklyn.
Give him that because producers will buy that fulfills.
And that's how like the acting stuff started,
you know,
and you know,
through the years I developed it and then you know,
when the Korea took off,
that's where the jackets became more elaborate.
Like from everything I learned from Elvis growing up,
his performance,
his style.
And I said,
well I don't want to be Elvis but I want to give people the Elvis of comedy,
you know?
And that's how the whole thing happened,
And then when Rodney gave me a shot on his special,
that was the best because I would watch all these fucking Bozo comics at the
store,
not working their ass off for that special.
And they know who they are.
You know what I mean?
So I don't,
I don't need,
but I'm saying like on those nights where he got three people in the audience,
they're going up and fucking around and they were going to be on the same
special with me.
And I'm going,
I don't give a fuck if the room is empty.
I just need to rehearse what I'm going to do.
Because I knew when I'd be in front of the cameras how nerve racking it is.
And I didn't want to have to think about material.
I just wanted to think about performed for the country.
Let them see what you've been working on all these years.
And you know,
three months later I'm in,
you know,
Nassau Coliseum,
it was that quick.
Jesus Christ know.
Yeah,
I did over 300 sold out arena shows at 20,000 people a night and nobody had ever
done anything.
Well that went on through knight from 88 to 95 and then it was the cutdown
arenas,
like 10,000 people a night.
I just kept going.
Wow.
You know,
and you know,
and then nobody had ever seen that kind of comedy before.
The difference between what you were doing with everybody else was doing.
It wasn't just that.
It was great stuff and it was funny and people are enjoying it and laughing.
Take it also to the rhymes along with you.
And people fucking loved that.
Well,
you know what,
those rhymes I still close with with the,
the mother goose stuff because it's almost like the hit.
Yeah.
We're working on this special now and even Max,
like even though he's a lot greener,
you know,
in the business,
he knows a lot about it and he goes,
Dad,
you've got to pull the hits.
He goes,
you've got all this great new stuff,
but you got to give them some of those hits because I made it 25 years ago.
It's not just that your stuff is more like a song,
like it's,
it's great to hear it again.
You know?
Like if I don't,
if I don't do those Rome's,
if I don't do the poems,
the audience is dramatic press.
Like why didn't he do the poem?
It's like going to see Leonard Skinner.
They don't do free bird.
That's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We,
I,
well,
you know,
I can't tell you how many times in my life I've heard what's in the bowl,
bitch.
It just became this gigantic thing that,
you know,
even now since entourage,
that was the resurgence that I've been taught.
I did a southern tour recently and I didn't know it was going to go on.
You know,
because I haven't really been out there in a decade.
And I was with Don Jamison and Jim Florentine from that metal show and they've
opened for me for years before they got the metal show and they would come over
to me and they go,
it's just happening all over again because the mania of the crowds now,
it might as well be 1988 and I didn't see that common.
You know,
I just didn't see it coming again.
You know.
But I'm also that type,
you know,
and I think you got that in you,
that fighter instinct that that belief in yourself that you can,
you can overcome anything,
you know?
And it was like,
you know what to do this special,
I'm going to give them something once again where they think they can't be
shocked anymore where they think it's all been done.
And it's not because I don't care what anybody does on stage.
I take my thoughts and I create these fucking pictures in their head that'll
like cartoons.
Cause I'm not a political comic.
I talk about,
you know,
from talking about technology,
I'm basically talking about,
you know,
even if you get on your computer to make believe you go into your email,
we know you're headed for the porn sites.
We know where people are gone.
That's what it's all about.
You know,
like even this new generation of women,
you know,
it's like they grew up on porn,
and I didn't come on here to do my material,
but that's what it is.
Like I've had a friend come to me and go,
yeah,
I went out with this chick.
I really liked her.
And,
and you know,
I wound up like doing everything with her the first night,
you know,
and some I could call her again because she's a real pig.
And I go,
you know,
I go,
but she did what you wanted her to do.
And maybe you're the only fucking guy she ever did that with.
Did you ever think of that?
You know,
maybe she doesn't do that with every fucking guy and she liked you enough to do
it.
I'm like,
I wound up marrying her.
Wow.
Strong guys.
No,
but I'm saying,
you know,
you can't,
I always loved sex.
I always,
you know,
the,
the reason I even got out to the women's stuff,
like with,
with,
uh,
what I do on stage is because when I grew up in Brooklyn,
I always had a girlfriend.
But you know,
I always treated them with a lot of respect.
I wouldn't even think a touch in that tit for the first couple months,
you know,
it was,
I just wouldn't do it,
you know,
unless they push the issue.
But when I moved to La in [inaudible] 80,
it wasn't even an 89 yet.
No,
it wasn't even 79 yet.
It was a whole different set of fucking rules out here.
Like I would try,
like if I met a girl,
why don't we go over to Ben Franked,
well,
where do you live?
I've got no,
we'll go for a bike while we could just go up to your house and hang out.
And then it was just one after the other.
And that's where the material would come from because girls that,
another guy would be writing a love letter to you know,
is now,
you know,
licking my balls.
Like she's the house dog,
you know,
and,
and I was like,
this is the subject matter right here.
You know,
that's where lines like treat me like the pig that I am because that's how they
want it to be treated.
But back then when my career took off an 88 and I did my special and I would do
you know that we're in the heels and the hair with that attitude,
like treat me like the pig that I am.
And women would get insulted from that back then they knew what fucking slobs
they were.
They just want to admit it today.
Did the most aggressive fucking generation I've ever come to know.
And it was like sex and the city did that start that?
Yeah,
definitely.
with the,
with the little piglets on there,
like it's okay to be a hooker.
Yeah.
And that's what,
that was a smart show because they didn't put,
you know,
women on there that with tens right.
You know what I mean?
They were okay.
You know,
so I do a bit on,
you know,
to sex in the city with Sarah.
Jessica got a face that looks like it did fucking prison time,
you know what I mean?
But the one that always got me was a Monad,
a short red hair,
whatever the fuck her name is.
And she,
that was an episode where she was talking about,
you know,
look in a guy's ass calling it in a cute way.
Tisha Lingus and I'm watching this going,
even if a girl wants to do that to me now,
I wouldn't want it because I'm going to picture this little pigeon face coming
out of my ass with a face full of shit,
you know,
with no tits concave that I'm going,
what do you do with concave?
Tits?
Put a scoop of ice cream in each fucking one.
You know what I mean?
So,
but,
but it was a smart show because women in America,
you know,
you know that warrant tech great looking could look at that show and go,
well if they could get all that Cox,
oh,
can I,
did you go,
you went through a period of time in your career where there was like so much
push back against your material and against like,
like you know what,
what they were calling,
you know,
misogynist comedy that didn't you like you like kind of cleaned it up a little
bit for a while.
Right.
I never cleaned it up.
What I did when I did,
um,
a series for CBS called bless this house they want to meet.
That's the fucked up thing with doing a network show they wanted to like,
like on that show,
they won't even put the credit as Andrew dice clay.
It was Andrew Clay and I'll never forget my,
my booking agent going,
what do they think?
People aren't going to know who it is.
You know what I mean?
And,
and that,
that's why it didn't told me down because this thank God the show got canceled
when it did because I was so bored every day I put on like 40 pounds in three
months playing a post man.
And you know when,
when and when the show got canceled.
This is the fun,
Max loves this.
The day of the show got canceled.
Like I was the happiest guy in the world.
I came home and I ran three miles,
you know,
my wife goes,
what's the matter?
Why are you home early?
I go,
the show got canceled.
I call them go and run in.
I've got to get ready for the special cause.
I booked the special with HBO for three months down the road and I had to get in
shape to do the special,
you know,
and the next day after the show was canceled,
I went to a canon drive in Beverly hills where Cathy Moriarity who started with
me in the show owned the pizza place and the whole cast this sitting around this
table outside like with the head in their hands.
Like,
how's everybody doing?
I get out of the truck or some coming to get dinner for my family.
Oh,
well,
you know,
I go,
yeah,
I know I got to grab a pizza.
I gotta get Outta here.
I was just thrilled.
This,
you know,
thrilled to death that I didn't have to show up at that studio anymore is one
that's one of the worst prisons for a comic is doing something that's not funny.
Well,
they really tied my hands.
I mean,
you know,
I would have,
fights with the producer of aligns,
you know,
especially when they make you say to were freaking,
which I always hate it.
I hate that word too.
Yeah.
I'm going,
you know,
like people don't know what you're saying.
Just write something else.
He goes,
well,
we're not a joke store.
I go then just send me the fuck home.
You know,
one time I did a line on that show,
he had this director,
the guy that did the pilot got the job direct and the season and um,
you know,
it was the opening of an episode.
And I walk in and the kids are watching TV and I come in and I go,
daddy made it through another day and I look at the TV.
I go,
by the way,
it didn't ever get off the island and you shut the TV.
Right?
So I come in and it's a full audience,
you know,
studio audience,
you know about it.
And uh,
you know,
psycho,
they never get off the island.
And before I click the thing,
I go,
I'll tell you that ginger keeps getting better looking.
And the director comes over,
he goes,
what are you playing to?
A bunch of fucking skinheads.
And I look at this guy and I go,
you know what?
You play my part.
I'm going home and I leave the studio.
And at that time I was with Michael Rotenberg was my manager,
but he was also a producer of that show.
And I get a call from him and he goes,
we're all you.
And I go,
I'm going home.
He goes,
you can't go home.
There's 300 people here.
What do you mean you're going home?
I go,
the guy fucking said this and I don't want to work with them anymore.
I don't want to do the show.
And he goes,
you gotta come back,
please come back.
We'll straighten it out tomorrow.
And I got to look,
I,
cause I'm like a five year old,
can I stop and get a slurpee first?
He goes,
get the fucking slurpee and get back,
you know?
And then they fired the director the next day and then they canceled the show
like four weeks later.
And I was
really happy about it.
My first show was ever on,
got canceled pretty quickly.
And it's a real similar thing.
There's a producer who was completely out of his head who rewrote everything
himself.
He Chile,
take it from the writers.
Really funny guys.
The guys who wrote the Simpsons,
they wrote married with children.
I was on a baseball show called hardball.
Yeah,
that one I don't know about.
It's terrible.
It was only on for like six episodes.
But the pilots moved to La and get series.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
I came out here for that show.
I was,
uh,
living in New York and I did the,
MTV half hour comedy hour and a,
when I did that,
I started getting all these development deal offers out of nowhere.
It was crazy.
I just did with this one,
one,
one little seven,
seven minute thing.
You get a TV show and I get banned for life from MTV.
I had never done any acting.
I didn't know anything about,
uh,
are you still band today?
Like could you,
you know what,
they invited me to this pissed a MTV awards to be in the audience,
you know,
so I guess the banding is over now,
but it was banned for life.
That's so ridiculous.
And then I'm watching Chris Brown who beat a girl to a pole,
you know,
flying through the air.
So in other words,
you know,
I can't say,
a couple of little,
you know,
rhymes cause the,
the,
the poem that got me banned was the,
um,
Jack,
oh no,
Jack Sprat could eat no fat.
His wife could eat no lean.
So Jack ignored a flabby tits and lick the Res Hall Clean.
And the reason I even did that material on the awards is because before I came
out,
you know,
a Cineo was hosting it and a Dick Clark,
I'm supposed to bring on share,
that was my job.
And Dick Clark comes over to me,
he goes,
look,
if you've got to stretch,
if she is not ready,
you know,
Cineo will come over.
And I go,
how can she be ready?
She's putting on a thong.
What won't you be ready for it?
You know,
I go,
don't send us any over.
We didn't prepare anything here.
And as he's doing this,
he's gone,
no,
you'll stretch.
I go,
please don't tell me what to fucking do when I'm out there.
You know,
and I'm thinking,
this is Dick Clark.
And I loved the guy,
you know,
and uh,
but now they introduce me and I came out angry and that were a couple of other
comics that were on that night.
Um,
you know,
Paul Riser came out then,
as a comic,
he's a good comic,
but he is talking about the hats that Frank Sinatra wore.
And I'm sitting in the crowd going,
nobody's paying attention.
And I had all this heat from the Rodney special,
I'm not going to go out there and bomb.
I'm going to let them fucking have it.
That's it.
So afterwards when they would take me into the press tense,
not one question was asked,
it was amazing to see.
And then the next day it was,
you know,
dice banned for life from MTV.
And then,
you know,
silly,
it was silly,
but it also,
you know,
up the career even more than the arenas with selling even crazier.
And you imagine that happening now being banned from
MTV now.
But your point about Chris Brown is such a good one,
started an internet campaign,
dice back to MTV.
You know,
would you be interested in a show if they they,
they were smart.
They'd have me host because since that,
since that award show,
nothing exciting has happened though.
What'd you list with?
Nothing that you don't understand.
I didn't get pressed for a week.
I got press for three
from that MTV.
They didn't even mention the fucking winners when it happened.
I was in every newspaper on every new show and I'm going,
I'm a fucking comic.
Like it was so overwhelming.
Would you,
would you live with a sneaky or a loader if you ha,
if they wanted you to know,
I don't want to do that kind of show.
You know?
I watched that show,
you know,
but you know,
I don't need snuck me in my life.
He's fun.
You know what I mean?
Lucky though.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
couldn't met him living with Kurt loader,
the loader or is that his name?
He's the guy.
The original guy.
Yeah.
Current load is the guy that had a talk about me being banned from MTV.
Who is it that got really
pissy about it though?
Somebody really dis,
it was really disappointing.
They were like massage and he is not funny.
And I'm like,
oh no,
I had every group the now organization over what it's like,
what kind of unrealistic expectations,
you know,
do these people have?
Well he also got understand comedy.
You got to understand that was when the whole,
uh,
the gays were coming out of the closet when I hit and I would do all the jokes,
like,
you know,
bisexual.
And I'm like,
what do you mean you either suck dick go,
you don't Suck Dick.
You know,
you know,
and it wasn't,
it wasn't hateful jokes.
It was just on the money,
you know?
And then the rest of the joke was,
what do you do?
Wake up in the morning,
flip a coin to decide,
you know,
to Joe,
it's,
you know,
it's offensive.
Comedy is a legitimate genre of comedy.
This is not get the respect that it deserves.
Well,
it's like I tell him,
Max,
be truthful on stage to talk about your life.
It's the funniest shit.
And it's proof positive that despite the fact that look,
thinking he could never put any of your stuff that you did,
they could never put it on the tonight show,
they could never put it on,
you know,
uh,
any,
any sort of mainstream show.
But yet you sold out arena after arena,
like no other comic.
So it's really ridiculous.
But even with the talk shows,
I used to look at them like,
you know,
you got a guy,
he is selling an 80,000 seats a weekend,
you know,
and guys like Letterman and Leno,
that wasn't good enough for them.
You know what I mean?
But you know,
your own talk show,
you know what,
I don't want to do a talk show.
I,
you know,
um,
what about on the Internet?
Would you be interested in doing like a podcast?
Not really.
No.
I'm just saying you could just turn on anytime you want.
What I'm going to do,
I'm going to do this special,
you know,
uh,
I see what's going on on the road and then I'm going to go into these big places
again.
I want to do the type of tour that fans have been wanting from me for years
So I'm making damn sure that this special,
you know,
just is a sledgehammer over people's heads.
And you know,
when I got all that negative press,
I wasn't expecting that when my career took off,
I didn't grow up going,
I want to be a controversial comic.
I didn't even think of this shit.
But the day after my first special Ed,
the dice man cometh the New York Times,
put the demise of Western civilization and that's what started all that shit.
But,
and it bothered me,
you know,
it was like,
wait a minute,
don't they get it?
I'm a comic.
But today,
you know,
I got all this history and I'm like,
who gives a fuck what anybody thinks about me?
You know what I mean?
As long as my kids know what I am and my wife knows what I am,
you know,
that's what matters to me.
If they want to write bad shit,
right.
Cause what I'm talking about there is truthful.
It might be in a cartoon sense when I'm talking about crazy sex,
you know,
and I'm talking about this new generation.
I'm talking about,
you know,
years ago you go out on a first date.
What'd you do?
You made out with the girl little,
maybe you've got some side tit through her coat that you could tell your
friends.
The next day I go,
this generation of women,
when you go out on a first date,
if you don't come all over her,
she thinks you don't fucking lie because I go,
I went on a second date with a girl.
She goes,
I didn't even think you were going to call because she didn't come on.
I'm going hunting.
I go tonight,
it's going to be like I put your head on the fucking yogurt machine and pulled
the
nozzle.
I go,
that's what it is today,
so why not be truthful about it and let people laugh over what fucking animals
they become.
One of my favorite things I know about you is that you always have a camcorder
and you're always documenting everything,
and like myself,
I did the exact same thing.
Are you ever going to take all that footage and digitize it and do a
documentary?
Well,
and that is people that want to do,
you know,
dice,
documentary or dice a documentary.
Um,
I'm talking with a,
you know who George Gallo is the writer.
He did movies like midnight run with Denae.
He's done a lot of,
you know,
he's got a 20,
what was it,
29 street guy who was in midnight run with um,
Growdon weird ever happened to that guy.
I don't know who gives a fuck.
I don't care if he fell off a cliff,
you know,
I don't get to,
why is he sitting there going,
I want the with dices.
Well you gotta do you,
do you care about John Travolta?
This whole story,
that juncture.
But you know what?
I think they should just leave fucking Travolta alone.
You know what I mean?
You know,
cause I'm a fan.
I've always been a fan and you know,
his personal life,
who gives a fuck what he does?
It's weird that that at least people were willing to jump on board.
Now,
like new messsage now are coming out and saying that he tried to grope them to
like
isn't an expected anyways.
Well it,
it's not just Travolta and you know why?
Like I said,
I don't want to do all this material I'm going to do on the special,
but you know when they make such a big deal,
you know,
with this new presidential race and these guys are coming up,
that shouldn't be gay marriage.
I'm going to wait a minute.
The country's falling apart.
Nobody could even fill that fucking gas tank without getting angry.
And you're worried if two guys want to want to put a ring on each
other's finger and say,
I fucking love you.
I would love to see a 24 hour camera on Travolta's love lights.
Come on.
He must be living like a savage.
I think it must be such a charge just to get guys,
like if he's getting massages,
he's John Travolta.
I bet.
How many guides you think he probably got to jerk him off like that?
Most of them.
Right.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm not saying on it.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fan too.
He's a fucking great,
but what I'm saying,
hell,
I'm one,
two,
three,
whatever the fuck it was.
The one with Denzel Washington,
the remake of that movie.
He's so fucking great bad guy.
I mean you forget sometimes what a bad motherfucker.
John Travolta.
He did swordfish.
He was bad.
And you know what I mean?
He was a bad guy in that.
Yeah.
I forgot all the pulp fiction was the resurgence.
This Pelham one,
two,
three or whatever the numbers were.
I think it's one,
two,
three.
He was fucking,
it was a stellar performance.
I mean,
he really comes off like a real psycho.
He died.
Motherfuck does motherfucker.
I was watching grease last night.
I love that.
Maybe not so stupid to say,
but I,
it's,
it feels like to try to knock a guy down this done and accomplished what he's
done in his life.
I would like the guy to be free.
I would like to guide to be able to just come out and say,
look,
I like girls and sometimes I like guys to,
what do you give a fuck?
Leave me alone.
That's what I'm saying.
We live in 2012 like,
I remember one time I was on how it's done and he goes,
uh,
this was over the last couple of years.
He goes the truth dice,
you know?
Did you ever like,
you know,
like,
like he plays like it.
Did you ever go gay or anything?
I got,
let me tell you something.
I'm in my early fifties.
Do you think if I wanted to suck Dick,
I'd be afraid to fucking say it.
You know what I mean?
If that's what I wanted.
If I wanted some guys bulls rolling around my face,
you type your fucking heaven and I wouldn't be shy about it and I wouldn't care
what they fucking said about it.
Cause that's what I like to do.
And something as you become a man,
you,
you really come to grips with that.
Dom Irrera was on the podcast.
He said,
I wish I was gay just so I could come out.
He goes,
look a little of a fuck.
I give
you gotta be,
you know what it is.
You will.
You get this one life you want with the self to be what you want to fucking be.
I just happened to love the box.
I always stayed since I'm a kid.
That's what I like.
It's all good.
Yeah.
I would like a guy like trivial to to,
to be in a society where it wouldn't even be an issue.
It's always going to be an issue.
They've got to have somebody yell about.
It's so silly.
It's just so dumb.
Who came?
Marriage people.
People can be in thrown out of their homes.
They want to talk about gay men and I think they talk about it cause they're
sucking.
Dick.
Then may asking,
how great would a documentary,
remember that Mike Tyson documentary when Mike Tyson just sat down and he
started talking about his life.
Yeah.
I show them how great would it documentary just Travolta sitting in a room just
on a chair by himself,
talking about how many different lists.
Who says he's got to suck his dick and just going over how he breaks them down.
He's not going to leave.
He's not gonna.
He's
not no disrespect.
I think the guy's a beautiful actor.
I think he's fucking fantastic.
I,
and I don't care what he does,
but I would think that would be a brilliant thing to watch because I got to
think,
he probably said deuces a lot of those guys.
A lot of those guys are probably straight guys.
I don't know.
I don't have to answer for something for whatever reason.
That's something that a lot of gay guys get a kick out of supposedly.
[inaudible] now we only got a minute.
Apparently he was telling dude's shit.
Like I actually admired his game.
He was telling dude's shit like I don't like elbows and I don't like forums only
hands and work exclusively on the buttocks.
And you know what?
I want his elbows and fucking it.
Right.
I'm constantly getting my bag.
I got the worst fucking back in history.
Yeah.
I've uh,
just gotten over a back injury.
You've got a back injury in Jujitsu.
It took like three months to heal.
When you get old.
Second.
I tell Max the only guy in comedy,
I'd never want to have a fight with Joe Rogan.
You're the only guy give it up to it.
I got any comic that's ever fucked with me.
I like look at them and go,
why would you want to do this to yourself?
Because I'm an animal.
You know what I mean?
I go,
Rogan is the real deal.
you got to be an asshole to come over at Tim and STI seem Rogan.
I seen Rogan go.
If there was fans outside the comedy club,
he would have an argument in the fuck it.
He's having an argument with this guy.
Well,
I'll tell you another argument,
which was even funny.
He has an argument with this Guy Max and the guy walks out and then if there was
show,
he comes out and continues with like 20 people between he's calling.
Fuck Yo,
what the fuck are you going to do?
And he's like spitting at the guy.
He hated him so much.
Well he had threatened one of the other comedians.
No,
I know.
I know how to deal,
but it was just so great to see because you have a temper like mine.
I go fucking nuts.
I got a bad temper and then one night you got mad.
This wasn't about a physical thing,
but we was sitting out back and just talking and this woman just said the wrong
thing to you about salt.
Like salt isn't good for you and you went,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Salt is a fucking,
what'd you say to them in a row?
Yeah,
it's a fucking mineral.
But I'm like,
like it was the most important thing in your mind.
Do you understand?
You don't know what the fuck you're even fucking talking about.
I'm going,
he's not even on stage and he's going Berserk and I'm like getting the show and
it went on for a good 10 minutes and she's gone.
No salt is that you don't know what the fuck.
You don't know anything about the body.
You don't know anything about nutrition.
It's a fucking mineral.
Oh,
you went insane over it.
And I'm going,
you know the man needs a couch.
It needs to talk to somebody.
That's all you know.
But it was hysterical.
You know,
anytime I'd seen you blow up like that,
like take it like I'd rather watch you outside screaming at somebody to watch
any 10 on stage.
You know what I mean?
It's so entertained.
That's why you love what you do.
Cause you know you go nuts.
You know,
you know you,
you know when you're on stage how you get,
you know,
it's fucking crazy.
I love it.
That's what I like to watch.
You know?
I can't sit there and go,
ha ha,
it's not good enough.
Ha Ha.
Just doesn't fucking work.
Not Today.
That mineral lady threw a cigarette at me.
Oh did she?
I don't remember that.
That was before that.
Well look at how you screaming at her.
She was scared to death.
No,
it was before that.
She threw a cigarette at me before that.
That's why I was pissed.
I was like,
why are you even here?
What are you doing?
You're just some crazy person hanging out back here.
Really interrupting conversations.
I'm much better now.
I've calmed myself dramatically over the years.
But what about on stage?
Oh yeah.
Well,
I mean it's dangerous until something ridiculous happens,
but I always a,
I tried to be friendly about it as much as possible.
Even while they're getting kicked out.
I should be interviewing you because I like,
I'll come over to Joe at the store,
I'll go,
what should I do for this muscle and that muscle because he knows that anything
you want to know about working out,
that's what you talked to Max to tell them what happened at the river a couple
nights ago when the guy got thrown out and then you came out.
Oh yeah,
I want to fight this guy cause I thought when I do,
you know,
somebody talks during my show or I see a phone,
I'll throw him out.
I actually throw them out,
you know,
and the funniest part of the whole thing,
like our warn him one time,
I go,
let me tell you something,
you're going to have to face the back wall for 10 minutes.
You know,
if,
if you do that one more time.
But the funniest part is when I decided to throw him out and security comes over
the look in their face like,
what are you kidding?
And like when they're thrown at what?
What was that?
You were fucking talking.
I was having a good time.
It's a comedy.
You were fucking talking and he told you don't talk.
So anyway,
I wasn't onstage at Eleanor was,
you know,
and all of a sudden I hear her going,
what the fuck is your problem?
I gave you eight fucking minutes already.
So I started screaming at the,
um,
the,
the producer of the show.
I go get that fucking guy added his fucking room before I go up,
I'll kill this fucking guy.
So now,
and I've never done this.
I'm in the back dressing room and I come out of the back and the guys out there
now who's coming to see me,
right?
And he's being read the riot act and being told to leave.
I go,
you mother fucker.
And he looks at me and he goes,
dice,
I just want,
I go,
I would have fucking thrown you out.
You're just a drunk and fucking cock sucker and he's gone.
But data,
I said,
I want to throw you down that fucking flight of steps.
Do you understand me?
I go,
I don't want you to be my fan.
I fucking hate your fucking guts.
And he's like,
he goes,
well yeah,
you want to make some,
you know,
and Max is there,
you know?
And I was like,
yeah,
throw you down that fucking escalator.
You understand me?
And now my
wife comes running over to Valerie and she's gone,
please go in the back.
That's what he wants.
I go,
I don't give a fuck what he wants.
I want to get my hands around his fucking throat.
That's what I fucking won.
And then,
then I'm hearing Eleanor start to introduce me from the showroom and there had
just come out to my music like nothing fucking happened,
you know?
And I noticed guys in his car flinging my cds out the fucking window,
And Max was like,
I don't give a fuck.
That was like the greatest thing that
we do.
Live comedy.
You can run across your sheriff fucking drunk retards,
trunk retards and assholes and crazy people to show.
But you know,
one of the things about working at the store was which you were guaranteed to
have confrontations.
The stores,
it's a vaulted time.
All the texts of crazy.
What are some of the funniest shows I ever saw was just you just attacking
people in the audience?
Well,
you know,
you came up with something that I've been using for years that I don't know if
came from you.
You were sitting with Eleanor one night in the back of the store and I was
ripping some guy apart and you told Elena,
you go,
I love when he turns into dice mean.
Yeah.
You know,
because a lot of them,
I actually,
the minute they talk,
I just hate that guts,
but it's for real.
It's not like a stage persona thing.
I just turned into myself now I'm just from Brooklyn again and it's like,
I want that person to know how much I fucking hate them.
You know?
It's like,
I know you brought up at the beginning,
you know,
this a puppet head,
whatever the fuck his name is,
that fucked with Max,
you know,
because you know,
he just,
and the reason he fucked with Max was because he just had a talk more on your
show.
He wanted more,
you know,
TV time,
whenever the fuck this computer is,
you know,
I don't really know about the technological world that much,
but that's why he opened his fucking mouth.
You know what I mean?
And it,
you know,
I'm not going to rip them apart,
I know the guy's a nice guy,
but he just shut his fucking mouth when somebody else is talking.
Just shut your fucking mouth because nobody cares.
What the fuck you got to say.
People that have no idea what any of this is about.
There was a show that we did with a good friend of ours,
Mark Ellis,
and uh,
he was sitting there with Max and Max was telling,
uh,
passionate tale of youth,
a passionate tale of a discovery and getting laid as a,
as a band member.
And,
um,
this guy kind of marked his tail saying,
well that's you're supposed to do when you're in a band.
I wouldn't,
it would be cool,
except you're only,
he wasn't was this guy 14 years old at the fucking a whiskey.
You know what I mean?
If you ever heard that music you,
you'd be blown out because they were off at record deals the second time at the
whiskey and my,
my other son,
Dylan,
who's four years younger than Max,
was only 14 at the time with Max or would we rather would mark said was totally
blown out of and when
I was talking red.
Yeah.
Me and my friends,
I know that he shouldn't,
the tall it was,
he was just,
I'm glad you're friends with him.
He was strictly,
when you got to face that looks like a squeezed all that your eyes,
nose and conquered pop out.
You should shut your fucking mouth when somebody is telling a story.
But now I'm going to end up running into him.
Oh,
it's going to be fine.
No,
it's fine.
You put a picture of my line.
You motherfucker.
Brian,
how dare you?
How you should just keep his mouth shut.
I liked the guy.
He's a good guy.
Dies.
I got nothing against [inaudible] joking around.
Right.
Max will tell you it was totally just a thousand wasn't even out here and go,
this guy,
when I see him,
I'm gonna see him at the store.
He's going to be loud handle this fucking guy doesn't have a malicious bone in
his body.
He's,
I'll get the pipe for this fucking guy.
He's a great bang.
His head to his fucking shoes and we'll see if he ever talks again with die.
No,
I'm just,
I'm just goofing around.
I liked,
I'm just kidding.
You know?
I would know.
You know,
I never picked my hands up to nobody.
You know that
Nice Guy,
puppet head.
It's amazing to get through the puppet Ellis.
Let's see how he gets laid with that name.
When a girl goes,
aren't you mock the puppet?
You know what I mean?
That's actually a great,
that should be the fucking quote on the cover of his book.
Well,
you know what,
mark,
have you write a book.
He used that as a quick mock,
the puppet and I like them.
I got nothing against the guy.
I see him every night at the store.
The store's about it now when I give a nickname,
it sticks.
That's it.
Anybody ever given nick pump too?
I think that story is about the gate caved in by that mountain in the back.
You know where everyone goes to smoke pot and sliding.
Big huge chunks are now falling from it.
Like the other day there's something hit the wall and it was a bit that's going
on for 30 years.
It hasn't been,
that's it.
He's always going on.
A mountain is going to fall into the store.
Right.
So if it does,
we'll perform on the street.
It is a,
it is kind of a crazy thing to have one of those houses up there above it.
I lived up there for six years.
You Crystal.
Yeah.
That was a beautiful place.
Nobody lived in that house longer than me.
Yeah,
I almost bought that house.
You want to hear the funniest story?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I've had a bunch of wives.
I got,
I got a brand new wife,
not only just got,
and um,
my first wife when,
when I married her,
you know,
we come back to La and she had an apartment like uh,
like off of fountain somewhere.
So we take a cab to her apartment,
we come back from New York and she goes,
okay,
tomorrow we'll go,
we'll pack all your stuff up and you know,
you'll move in here and I'm standing in.
I go,
uh,
um,
I'm not moving out.
She goes,
what do you mean you're not moving out?
I go,
I got to stay in crest till,
till I make it.
I go,
I'm not going to live with you.
She goes,
you married me.
It's not like I won't see you,
you know,
I'll come over a lot.
She actually used to come by my house.
Wow.
Seven o'clock in the morning on her way to work.
Cause I was in the maid's room in
crestal and I'd sleep with the windows open and had those,
you know,
to Spanish House with the boss.
And she barely like Andrew and go,
yeah.
And she goes,
no,
I just want to stop by.
I'm going to work.
I go,
yeah,
I'll call you later.
We'll go out tonight.
You know,
because,
you know,
it was like an emergency wedding.
And uh,
cause she thought she was pregnant at the time,
whatever.
And,
and I wouldn't move in with us.
So she moved into,
so she winds up moving into crest hill,
you know,
she moves into Crest Hill and I said,
don't tell anybody we're married.
Nobody could over now.
And she goes,
why not?
I go,
well,
your parents can know,
but I go and build in a certain image,
you know,
I was like 26,
like,
Oh,
you know,
and I married you for you,
not really for me,
you know,
so,
when you had this baby,
you know,
it'll be legitimate,
whatever.
And uh,
she goes,
so nobody could even know were married.
I got like if,
why?
We know we're married,
you know,
and obviously that marriage fell apart.
She moved into Crest Hill and,
and Mitzi threw us out,
you know,
cause she didn't want girlfriends up there.
God forbid she knew I got married and uh,
but I was in crestal for over six years.
Did Mitzi ever give you advice?
Yeah.
Not to do the act I was doing because,
because she couldn't figure it out too when she couldn't figure it out.
I go,
it's never been seen and that's why I knew it would work.
It was almost like taking the kind of characters you would see like Travolta,
doing movies,
like,
you know,
Tony Minero,
those kinds of,
and putting them on a comedy stage.
That was my idea.
Wow.
That was a,
an interesting time to Mitzi.
Another time.
Tommy.
All right,
here's another time I knew I was going through the roof.
My second album,
which was called the data laughter died,
was a double CD with like no people in the audience from Dangerfield.
Yeah.
So you know the album.
No.
Okay.
Well.
So Mitzi,
well,
let me tell you about how I was introduced to it by a guy named Mike Donovan who
was a top notch Boston College.
Really Funny Guy,
but a local guy when I was guys just never leaves and he is in fucking tears
crying in the back of of the the common connection and he was listening to this,
this a cassette and he's crying,
tears are coming out of the guy can't breathe and you're doing this thing about
doing Nixon in a girl's ass like doing it and mixing impression.
Why you eating the girl's ass?
And I'm telling you,
Mike Donovan,
he's fucking crying.
He goes,
this is the greatest CD I've ever heard in my life.
And he goes to the fucking guy just goes into a club.
No one knows he's going to be that.
It's 10 people in the fucking audience.
And he has no,
no,
nothing planned.
Does whatever the fuck he wants talks about whenever he wants.
He walks the whole crowd,
there's screaming and yell at him.
He goes,
it's fucking brilliant.
And he goes and he put it all on a CD.
He's,
this guy was crying,
tears were coming down his eyes,
his face was red Wilson until you do next it.
What happened with that album is,
uh,
I was doing the arenas at the time.
So the first album was a high powered album.
And,
uh,
and of course we also recorded the guard and that was an album dice rules.
But then I do,
I want to do a concept of the ultimate late night set.
So Rick Rubin was the producer,
but David Geffen would put out the albums.
So first I get a call from David Geffen going,
uh,
I heard the new album.
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
uh,
he goes,
I don't get it.
I go,
what's not again?
He goes,
there's no people you know,
and you hit people walking out on you.
And I go,
well,
it's a concept.
It's the ultimate late nights said.
He goes,
okay,
but why does it have to be a double CD?
Cause it's like two and a half hours,
two and a half hours.
And I go,
because it's never been,
nobody's ever done anything like that.
He goes,
okay,
it's your career.
You know,
now Mitzi wants to hear some of the new album.
So she comes up to my house like late at night,
I'm with my friend and we stopped playing it for her and she's sitting there
listening and she starts smoking,
you know,
she smoked cigarettes at the,
and she goes,
Andrew,
um,
this is gonna ruin your career.
I go,
you don't like it?
You know,
I'm like goofing on it.
She goes,
no,
I don't like it.
She goes,
you playing the La Forum,
why would you put this out?
I go,
it's never been done.
Why don't people understand that shit?
So the album comes out and it goes gold in four days.
And to this day it's the,
the favorite album of any of my fans.
It's the dead.
I actually did a sequel.
The data left or died part too because people loved it so much.
Well,
it's such a real moment,
you know,
when that got you're about as funny as a glass of milk yet,
and I,
any other comic would have cut that out of the album.
I wanted that reaction.
It was an,
it was an,
uh,
you know,
it was like a late night tourist crowd.
They're not expecting a perfect,
you know,
I had like some Bachelorette party there,
I'm telling them,
you know,
I forgot what's even on the album because I was making it up.
You know,
I had some notes in my pocket that said like,
bet Midler shit.
Yodels nobody believes me.
You know that people,
when they run into me,
they go,
what did that mean exactly?
What does our back mean?
You know,
I'll call you in an hour back,
get it.
But he keeps saying it like swine and I never talk about it.
That's,
I never give up on my own.
Goofs you know,
and uh,
you know,
and I never will.
That's a goof to fucking very high scale though.
Yeah.
That album when it,
you know,
I mean,
but the speed of the sales and how much people loved it.
Like if it was the computer age,
it would've just been a million tweets and a million.
Well,
what people loved it.
What,
what they loved about it is,
first of all,
there was nothing like it.
No one ever put a CD out of a 15,
20% audience,
half the people leaving and yelling at them.
No one,
no one's ever done.
Well.
The second one ends with a,
I got a fight.
This guy,
you know,
I was looking on the second on the second day to laugh the died,
cos there's no beginning,
middle or end.
I'm looking,
how am I going to end this?
And these two couples come in and they're drunk and I forgot what they were even
saying,
but I get into it with the guy and then I dropped the mic to go after him and
the album goes to nothing.
That's how the men's,
because uh,
at that time club Soda Kenny,
who was my body,
God,
he jumped on me as I was running to jump on the guy because he didn't want me to
have a multimillion dollar lawsuit.
You know,
I love club.
So it Kenny.
Yeah,
but,
but yeah,
all stuff like that would always go on.
But this was recorded.
That's why it was so great.
And then those people was still there when I was done recording and I went over
to thank that guy for getting me angry and explain to the guy,
because I had no end for the album and now I do.
So I bought the guy a drink,
you know,
because I caught him coming over and out to fight them because they had a ball
and I'm like,
no,
I don't want to fight you.
That was great.
Inside the album happened.
I now have a great ending.
Nobody's going to know what happens once I dropped the mic because I really got
crazy.
Like I lose it.
I don't know what happened.
It's what always happened to me,
you know?
Well,
you're also in that enhanced environment when you're on stage,
you know when you're,
when you're jacked up like that on stage,
especially when you're in the middle of something.
It was a Guy Hecklin uh,
yeah.
He was just yelling shit.
Oh,
you know,
when I get somebody's too drunk and an audience,
that's when I lose it because I make no excuses for adults.
I just don't,
that's why,
you know,
with the puppet,
he's an adult.
I don't make an excuse for mark.
Mark [inaudible].
He's a good guy.
I love the guy.
He fucked up.
You know he did fuck up though.
Now he knows it.
Now he knows wherever reverend,
I guess.
Yeah.
And,
and when he sees me at the store,
he shouldn't even bring it up.
That would be the smart,
the smart things.
Correct.
Yes.
Don't even talk about it.
I don't want to get mad.
I've been trying to maybe say a hello sir.
Sometimes it might be nice.
Yeah.
How you doing,
Mr. Clay?
I'm gonna now have to have a conversation.
Let him know what's cool.
No,
but I love that Max is doing the comedy and he actually worked beautifully last
week in Vegas.
He did it down here at the ice house couple of weeks ago and killed it.
Everybody awesome.
Came back towards so much.
It's amazing,
man.
It's,
it's beautiful to see.
I mean,
you are the son of one of the all time greatest comics.
that's a fact.
Dice is without a doubt.
One of the all time greats in my,
in my book,
he's right up there.
There's,
there's only a few comics.
There's only like a room for like if you had room for top five,
like five greatest comics of all time.
He's in there for sure 100% you are the son of that dude.
Stop and think,
but it's not a big,
I don't make it a big deal with them.
I never
did.
You should know,
but he does know.
He knows the history.
He knows it all.
But I always,
I always taught Max and doing,
you know,
they know who I am,
but it's always make your own road,
you know what I mean?
You know not to live in my shadow.
If you do comedy and do your own kind of comedy.
What,
remember I ran into you at the Improv and you were telling me how he was doing
comedy and you were so proud of him.
Man.
It was really cool to see.
Well,
if you were,
you were so happy that it was,
it was working out well for him.
He just had a set and just killed.
And you could see you have this like just a real genuine appreciation of it.
It was,
you know what it is.
He also has the work ethic,
you know what I mean?
He's had it every night.
He doesn't even let me come where he performs unless he's working with me.
And I can't blame him because a man,
you don't need that pressure in,
in the crowd of me watching you.
But in Vegas I would make mental notes and we talk about like,
he'll come home like two in the morning and I'll be out like on the curb.
Like I'm in Brooklyn Smoking cigarettes and we'll first talk comedy till four
o'clock.
Oh,
that's awesome.
That's awesome.
You know,
so I mean,
he knows what he's doing and he'll be on the special too.
Does it give you an extra,
like an extra push senior son going through the whole beginning stages,
you know,
and was seeing him,
putting together an act.
Does it like,
charge you up for it?
Like make you more creative or more,
more,
uh,
more excited about it?
What you know,
I always believed in teaching kids by example.
Like I'm,
I'm one of those fathers that actually raised my kids and a big part of,
of what I'm doing now.
And yeah,
it's a personal thing.
It's like it's a job that's unfinished and that's why the special is going to be
my last special.
I'm actually going to do it at the Wilbur Theater in Boston.
And because Boston's always been great with me.
It's like a second home from Brooklyn,
Boston,
Philadelphia,
you know.
Um,
so I'm going to do it there.
Max is going to be part of that show and you know,
he's going to show what he's got on that show and that's beautiful.
And,
but I always taught them by example.
And by me doing this by me training physically and mentally and being on stage
every night shows him that even after all these years of comedy,
I'm not taking this special and going,
all right,
I'll do the little special and see what happens.
I'm making sure that every comic watching this thing,
especially the haters,
sit there and go,
fuck,
why?
Why does he still have that fucking thing?
You know what I mean?
Because,
you know,
I'll be honest about,
uh,
right before I got entourage,
I was about a 42 waste.
Okay.
And then I got entourage.
I'm like,
all right,
I can't be the fat guy in the entourage.
So I started training and I got in good enough shape to do,
to show,
and then I kept going because I don't just think of,
well,
let's see what happens from entourage.
I didn't wait for the phone to ring.
I'm 10 steps ahead thinking,
okay,
start touring,
build up to the special than there were major tour.
Uh,
I was with David Rich last night.
he's going to do my autobiography.
He's done people.
He did don Rickles.
As far as comics,
he's done Marvin Gaye.
He did.
Uh,
wow.
what's the movie?
Jamie Foxx starting?
Uh,
Ray Charles.
He wrote that book.
Uh,
he's written a ton of books and now he wants to do mine and George Gallo wants
to do,
uh,
the,
the moving,
you know,
with your play.
You.
Well,
I let Max tell you how that came about.
Yeah,
you can tell him the story.
Who should play me?
Well,
uh,
the name that I guess we've all been discussing is a James Franco and I met with
Franco about two and a half years ago to discuss the movie and because he would
have that look of me like in the 30s,
like when I was in my thirties,
he can act as fucking ass off.
He can do it.
By the time we met for about three hours,
by the time he left my hotel,
he was doing not dice.
He was doing Andrew.
I mean,
he's a real method actor.
He would know how to play that role perfectly.
He's a,
he's a real fucking actor.
Yeah.
I mean,
you,
you do a roll.
I hit him.
There he is.
You know,
and you know,
he's,
he's the type of guy that like,
he'll move in with you to learn everything you do.
Did you ever see,
um,
uh,
fear and loathing in Las Vegas where Johnny Depp Played Hunters Thompson?
No,
he lived with hunters Thompson lived in his basement for like six months.
It's hanging out with that crazy old asshole while he was like shooting guns off
his back porch,
you know,
a hunter hunter s Thompson was gone.
Well,
depth is incredible depth.
As you know,
I did a movie with Johnny Depp,
made Johnny Depp and uh,
Rob Morrow,
you know,
rob morrow,
he starting quiz show had,
did the show northern exposure and we did this movie called private resort.
It was one of Johnny debt.
This is a funny story.
Um,
so it's me,
Johnny Depp and Rob Morrow and even the producers said,
the three of you guys are going to be made just stars,
you know,
and then I met,
you know Jim Schubert?
Sure.
Okay.
So I was friends with Jimmy Schubert back then and I would go and Jimmy Schubert
thought he was going to be James Deane.
Okay.
And I would say,
well,
you're not going to be James Deane.
But on top of that,
you know,
Johnny Depp,
and he would laugh because he didn't know who Johnny Depp was yet.
You know,
Johnny Depp was unknown and he goes,
fuck it's Johnny Depp.
I go,
Johnny Depp is James Deane.
Trust me.
You know,
and then,
um,
jump street happened,
21 jump street and Schubert comes to me.
He goes,
there really is a Johnny Depp.
That was a name you made up like one of your names,
you know,
I go,
I'm telling you this is the real deal.
And Johnny obviously has had an incredible act in Korea,
you know,
and every time I see him it's like I did that movie with that guy who's done all
these great,
you know,
it's like honor when you get to work with somebody that blew up like he did.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's all time and he's amazing,
but Franco's the right age to play the main part of that movie.
And he would be doing all your materials.
So would you,
would you coach them?
You're going to like,
he would,
he,
that's a guy that moves in with you,
learns about your whole life,
you know,
from what you are off stage to what you are on stage because he's got to play it
all,
you know.
Fascinating.
What is,
what part of your life is it going to cover when you explode?
No,
from childhood on,
but not much about childhood because a lot of that movie which show what really
went on with the controversy,
how,
you know,
how they pulled the,
uh,
premier afford failing,
which was going to be at the La Forum.
You know,
I mean,
a lot went down.
The studio heads lives were being threatened by the gay community.
You know,
Barry Della was day with Tom.
They're going to blow up his house with a pipe bomb.
I mean,
that was all they were plastering up.
You know,
I was with Sandy.
Gowan was my manager.
David Geffen put out the albums and buried della was the movie studio.
So the,
you know,
the gay community,
what posting them on all the,
uh,
like telephone poles in Hollywood saying how they have to get rid of this guy
and,
you know,
and it wound up a mess.
It wound up,
you know,
I got blackballed.
I got banned,
you know,
I got banned from everything,
including my cousin,
uh,
Herschel's bar Mitzvah,
Leonard's in Long Island.
I had a [inaudible] when I was first starting out.
I was,
I was dirty,
you know,
and a open mic guys.
The open mic,
a host would always tell you,
oh,
you gotta clean it up.
You got to clean it up.
And they would say like,
what do you think your dice clay?
And he dies,
clay.
No,
you're not.
So clean it up.
But I'd probably put,
how did dice clay get to be dice clay?
I mean,
it doesn't,
that's right.
Can you just,
if it's funny,
isn't that enough?
Well,
you know what,
the first time I did Vegas with the dunes,
when Mitzi had the dunes there,
I got fired the second night because what she would do,
she would rehearse the comics act.
You had to rehearse for her and do the jokes exactly the way you rehearsed it.
Just to the shroud.
Yeah,
just her.
So now the show happens and now it's alive crowd.
So of course I just go into,
you know,
all my gay material and you know I'm doing what I have to do to the crowd
because I'm closing the show.
Right.
So we have to the show,
she goes,
I told you to stick to the act.
You rehearsed.
I go,
I'm not a puppet.
Did we say that word today?
Anyway,
I'm fucking around.
I go,
I'm not a puppet.
And I got Mitzi,
you know about talent,
you know how to pick talent,
but you don't know the feeling on stage.
When you've got an audience you have to go the way the audience is going.
So the second night after my set,
I actually come over to it cause I know I'm going to get fired and I go,
look,
don't feel bad about sending me home.
And she goes,
I don't,
you know.
And it was funny because I sat in that showroom after then I go,
you know what,
they're just not ready for you yet.
And it was funny outside,
right across the street was Bally's and the marquee read Tom Jones is here.
That's how he would,
you know,
have it on the marquee.
And I go,
well that's where I'm going to be.
And two years later,
you know,
there's my name up at Bally's,
so I just knew they weren't ready for me yet,
but I stuck to my guns.
I did my material the way I thought I should and I always have and I still do.
It's one of those things that if you compromise and just tried to make everybody
happy from the beginning,
you would have never found that audience that I'll be back in a clothing store
going,
what are you a 42 regular?
That's what I'd be doing.
It's amazing how you just sort of calculated it all out though.
Well,
I'm doing it again though.
You know,
like I know the day after New Year's and this is not,
you know,
you have the career you have,
which is to me an incredible career.
I mean,
you've gone,
between fear factor and what you did,
how you took it back to the martial arts and doing your comedy that way,
you know,
you get my respect.
If you didn't have any of them be here.
Thank you very much man.
Thank you.
Great.
I was watching you when you first came to the store.
That's why I would even take the time to give you some advice.
I really appreciate it.
Me.
That was huge.
It was,
it meant a lot to me.
Well,
you know what,
when I,
when I met Dane Cook and he was doing the bigger places,
you know,
uh,
I actually met him day,
his father passed away and,
uh,
a better in Beverly hills and he was telling me how I influenced them and I felt
good that I'd been sticking up for the guy because I never knew who the guy was
until he took off.
And you know,
just like all these scumbag comics,
that's why I hate these guys.
They all stab you.
You know how they are,
and they're on the back of the comedy store.
They're not even on that night.
You know,
they're making nothing going.
Oh,
he's a fucking thief.
He's this.
He's that.
He took my Ba,
I go,
well,
why didn't you go off and smack them in the face five years ago for taking your
bed,
but not at the guys doing great.
He's not funny.
He's no good.
In the meantime,
he's drawn 10,
15,000 people a night and you're not making $20 tonight.
He hit some rarefied air.
That's what,
you know.
So yeah,
I would always back,
you know,
an m and m took off how people would come down on him.
And I became friends with him over that.
Um,
actually m and m,
uh,
was going to do seven albums with me.
He gave me a deal for seven cds that he was going to produce.
And at that time I had no heat on me.
And,
uh,
he was with I think,
emi and they said,
we're not giving him the deal because there's no heat right now.
But that's how I became friendly with m and m.
And it was all of a sudden when actually the story with m and m,
what year would you say?
There was no heat?
I had nothing going on from around 2000 on and till,
till recently.
And so his entourage,
you think 100% for all those?
I start,
well,
what happened is obviously I went through divorce and it was,
you know,
my personal life's always been more important than me then,
a Korea life.
So yeah,
I would do the road and I would do my gigs,
but I didn't have the management.
I didn't have the publicists,
the publicists out there.
All I really cared about was,
uh,
Matt when I left my boys with seven and 11 years old.
So it was more important for me to be around and raise them the right way.
And they both live with me and you know,
and then I always,
but I prepared,
you know,
through this whole past decade,
as bad as it was,
I would work on the new material and say at the right time I'm going to hit him
again.
You know,
because if you walk around telling people you're the undisputed comedy king,
well if you do another special,
you better prove that,
you know,
and that's the bottom line.
And so you like challenging yourself,
like completely make yourself rise to the occasion.
I Cha,
you know,
Max can't tell you how I trained for this thing.
You know what goes on in the gym.
You,
Louis,
Louis Ck does that to Louie told me that he trains for a special,
like a fight.
Like he helped me gears up,
but you get some shape now.
You explained my dad really?
He trains like a bodybuilder,
you know,
it's not even like I got to lose five pounds.
It's like,
no,
I got to put on 10 pounds of muscle and drop 20 pounds of whatever.
But uh,
yeah,
we're always in the gym.
Always training the guy that actually trains Stallone for rocky.
When I was getting ready to do Ford Fairlane,
I became friends with Stallone and he introduced me to his train.
And the guy's name is George Pippa sick.
And the guy was from Czechoslovakia and he was,
he was missed to Czechoslovakia four years in a row.
And then when steroids came into the business,
he quit and moved to America and he built,
he didn't just open a private gym,
he built every,
he was also a machinist and built every machine in that gym.
And when this guy really taught me how to change my body,
when I have to change it had an amplify any muscle,
you know,
um,
so with,
with this special,
you know,
I am,
I'm 54 years old and when I walk out there,
it's almost like when I see certain guys in the crowd that are my age or old,
and I ask how old they are and they go,
you know,
I'm 55 years old and I'm looking at the guy like he's 75.
So it's like,
I almost want to be hopeful to those people because even as you get older,
one of the other things I would call myself as like the rocky of comedy.
Like I'll watch rocky six and go,
that's where I am and that's who I am.
You know?
And you know,
his messages in those movies about taking your life in,
reaching your potential is what I always use.
So yeah,
I could just throw on a leather and walk out there and have a belly sticking
out,
you know?
But it's like,
why do that when I'm more than capable of completely restructuring my body and
giving the fans exactly what they want from it.
And it makes you feel like you're gearing up for something.
Yeah,
it does.
You know,
I go up the mountains,
I got her to gym and you know,
Max had the funniest line.
Uh,
there was this producer in the gym the other day that,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to get on the treadmill and he got on one of these,
uh,
bouncing things,
you know,
and I go,
why don't you do the workout with me?
You know,
and he goes,
you know,
why am I going to work out with you?
And Max is Stan there.
But this other guy comes over to it works and golds.
Uh,
his name is Travis.
And he goes,
because he knows what he's doing.
And this Guy Travis is what like 30 years old and he's completely ripped.
He's like six [inaudible] two and he goes,
when I trained with dice,
I shake when I'm writing the next day he goes,
that's how hard he trains and what he does to each muscle.
So when Max gets me alone,
he goes,
you know,
cause in the gym,
like you could be in a tank top,
you're in different clothing.
And Max goes,
why would this producer even question you?
You have worked out.
It's on,
you know,
and you know,
it just cracked me up because you know,
people you know,
look to instead of building up,
they always look to knock you down.
And I always use those negatives to propel myself.
See before I walk out on stage,
I gave Chris rock the same advice before he did bring the pain.
And it's actually a funny story because I came into the comedy store and Chris
was on stage,
rehearsing is material and it came to the back and,
and I mean Chris,
we will bonding is,
we're both from Brooklyn,
went to the same high school.
I'm like 10 years old and item,
but we always had that bond.
So I said to Chris,
I go,
uh,
you know what,
what's going on with your life?
He goes,
well,
you know,
I'm getting ready to do this special phage be,
oh,
you know how many they're going to get me?
And I look at him and I go,
let me ask you something.
I go with friends,
right?
And he goes,
yeah,
I go,
does it bother you at all that when you leave this club,
every comic looks at you like a fucking zero.
And he's looking at me going,
why would you say that?
I go,
because that's how they look at you.
You're a fucking zero in their eyes.
You've done nothing or limit Eddie Murphy did for you.
How does that sound?
That's what they think of you.
He goes,
why would you said I go?
Because you're standing and talking about a special,
like it's just another special I go when when a network like HBO or showtime
that give you a special,
they're giving it to you because that's what they think you are.
And if you treat it with the attitude,
you just said it to me with,
that's what's going to happen.
Nothing.
I go when you are behind the stage and you're thinking you're going out there in
two minutes,
think of every comic watching go and he's a fucking zero.
And you know what the other side of your brain should be thinking about the
family that's been back in your ass all these years and they're praying for you
and you use both those things and start moving around on stage a little because
you stand there like a fucking soldier and as good as your material is,
people are going to fall asleep watching you.
And that's when he developed that crazy walk back and forth.
So you coached him into that?
I coached him with that.
Nothing about his material.
He gave me a thank you on the special,
you know,
and um,
and he scored and became a big star because he listened.
Because what I do know,
he listened because what I do understand Joe is about performance because they
studied rock stars.
I studied the greatest of the greats.
If it was with the drums,
it was buddy rich.
You know what I mean?
The greatest drum had ever lived,
but he was doing,
uh,
shows when he was two years old.
Wow.
You know,
so I studied the greats.
I didn't study comics because like I keep telling you,
they bought me to fucking tears.
You know what I mean?
The only one,
like a Rodney Dangerfield or don Rickles,
when I watched Don Rickles,
I'm on the floor banging my hands laughing because he's a fucking animal.
He gets it.
You know what I mean?
Other guys come out there.
Well,
you know,
I started dating.
I go,
just fucking move.
You know,
even with Max when he's performing in Vegas,
I go,
just take a pace,
grab that Mike and stop pacing a little and they will follow you and they'll be
with you.
But if you just stand in one spot,
they're going to get tired and start nodding off just to the sound of a voice.
It's true.
It's excellent advice.
It is.
Yeah.
Hashi Joey Diaz.
Joey Diaz just stands there.
Yeah.
Well look at them though,
man.
To the human mountain screaming at an audience.
You're going to pay a 10.
I love Steve.
You don't,
you know what's so funny about Diaz?
Um,
you know,
my,
my new wife,
she's a,
she's hair flat and in here,
uh,
battalion Jewish whenever she is,
but years ago,
you know,
Diaz was talking about girls and you know,
he's talking about Latin girls.
He goes,
you don't want that Latin Pussy.
You never want Latin person.
You know,
Eh,
you know,
like,
oh,
how come?
You know,
he goes,
because you never get out.
You know,
he goes,
you never get out the fucking crazy.
It's the hardest shit on the fucking planet.
Do you understand?
You don't want to go near that.
This is,
you know,
20 years before I met my wife,
but now I know what the fuck he's talking about.
That's,
that's classic Joey Diaz.
Oh No,
he was on those bags.
Get out dog.
No,
he was on the back staircase talking about Cuban food and every other fucking
food.
Fucking stab you while you're coming.
Yeah,
no.
You know what he's right.
Yeah.
Oh I was talking about of Latina girl that I was dating when I first listened to
your cassette and I was 19 that bitch was off the charts.
Nothing like it.
Nothing
like it.
You know,
I'm married my wife within a year's time.
Wow.
And we've been happy ever since.
He just said,
I'll take it other than when we're breaking the house apart,
you know,
cause at the beginning,
so,
you know,
it was always funny cause you know,
if we got into a fight,
I'm fucking leave and he'd go to bags,
a rolling out,
I'm throwing them down the stairs,
Max's look in.
And it got to a point where,
where my sons would be like,
you know what?
We're not even going to pay attention to this anymore.
How are we breaking out?
Well,
at the beginning a lot,
you know,
like every other day.
No,
there was,
there was a couple months stretch up,
but she's the only girl,
you know,
number one,
my wife,
you know,
knows more about me than me and she's a lot younger than me and she has studied
it now.
And like she was a dice fan.
No,
she wasn't a dice fan.
A friend,
when I met her,
her friend knew everything about me,
but she didn't even know who I was.
So once,
once we started going out,
she started on the Internet and studying it and she watches every show I do.
And she's the one that got me into the social media with the fucking Twitter
shit.
You know,
years ago when people would go,
dice,
do you tweet?
I go,
you know what a pussy.
That's as far as I take it,
you know?
But,
but she got me into all that stuff and you know,
she's good with the material.
I never listened to anybody about material,
you know,
in my whole life,
any woman I went with,
any,
any friend,
but she actually knows she gets it and she'll give me like little things to say
and it kills,
you know,
she really just gets what I do and really studies it.
That's hilarious.
So she's almost like she can be a writer too.
Well,
cause she knows you so well.
She,
she's my number one fan.
She's my groupie and she's the only one I want.
Trust me.
You know,
you've met her,
she's great.
She's great.
Valerie,
I hope you're listening.
So,
uh,
she's also on a Twitter under miss dice clay.
Yeah.
She loves being Mrs Dice Clay.
She loves it,
you know.
Yeah.
She sells,
she does the merchandise at the shows.
Oh yeah.
That's awesome.
And like I'll talk about my Latin wife.
I go,
yeah,
you know that the day after we got married,
a mother moves in.
Then the father and the 90 cousins come,
90 cousins,
half of them are and cousins.
And I'm going to,
oh,
I know it's helped my fucking truck is missing,
you know,
but she's got the greatest family.
I carry a picture of a model,
which is a step w where's my beer?
I got to show him this.
This is an,
I don't have a picture of my wife on me.
So your,
Twitter's the real dice clay,
the real dice clay.
Anything else is not.
Um,
is that your fanny pack?
Yeah,
I have my little love fake bag.
I enjoy the fanny pack.
And I'm proud of you for sporting one as well.
The list.
Yeah,
it's a great way.
In a nice picture.
I carry of a month,
take a look.
Oh wait,
where's the mother?
Is The mum?
There's Mama seat.
The senior
as May.
Look how handsome
for my wife will see that sugar.
You took out the wrinkled picture.
Ford Fairline used to be.
But I gotta tell you this though,
because obviously you're friends with Eleanor.
Eleanor's like my extra wife and um,
you know,
so she,
she also opens the shows for me.
So anytime there's a problem with me and Eleanor.
Eleanor goes to my wife and now I got to get it in the dressing room from the
two of them.
Max has witnessed this.
It's hysterical.
You hang up on them.
They do.
Does he enjoy it a little bit?
Yeah.
Yeah because I see,
you know,
they both have different towns.
Like you know,
I told you about my neck,
you know,
my wife's a little lazy about it cause she's got like fingernails like longer
than your foot,
you know?
And they're always like different things whenever she does.
But Eleanor,
she south Philly,
so she gets in there with the elbows,
you know what I mean?
So it'd be like,
oh no,
you've got to work on me tonight.
You know what I mean?
And she'll like dig in for a good hour.
So yeah,
it's all different styles from a lifting your your back.
Yeah.
I just always had a bad neck and back.
Do you stretch a lot?
No,
I don't stretch enough.
I know,
I bet you told me that.
Yeah.
It's also your hamstrings.
A lot of times when people are experiencing pain and tightness in their back,
it really has a lot to do with your hamstrings,
you know,
uh,
if you don't have a flexible back,
um,
you know,
you gotta think about all the different ways your back do stretch.
I just don't stretch and a strong as I should.
I stretch a lot,
especially as you get older,
single view in one of the,
uh,
martial arts magazines,
like doing the split.
Yeah,
I can do that.
And that's when I decided never have a problem with,
never have a problem with him.
He knows too much flexibilities.
The one of the most important things as you get older,
especially,
you've got to really,
it's something you have to do,
like brushing your teeth.
If you don't brush your teeth,
you know,
you can go to bed and not brush your teeth for a few fucking months and nothing
really will happen except you get bad breath.
But you got to think about stretching like that.
It's like,
it's a,
it's an important piece of body maintenance,
especially as you get older.
And then as you're younger,
especially if you're younger and you're lifting weights,
there's a lot of people that fucked their body up because they lift weights and
I don't stretch out.
You got to make sure you get a full range of motion.
Do you still talking about that?
Do you actually still fight?
I still do Jujitsu.
I do Jiu Jitsu sparring,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know any kickbox anymore because a,
I hit the bag and I work with trainers and hit the pads and stuff.
But sparring is not good for your brain because you're an interesting guy.
I mean you,
you went,
I mean that to learn what,
what degree are you,
oh well I stopped taking taekwondo,
which was the martial arts that I first got my black belt.
Then when I was a second degree and I stopped because I started getting into
kickboxing,
I started getting into Moy Thai.
So I,
I missed mixed all this other stuff in with the taekwondo and sort of changed my
whole style and kicking.
So that was the last time I was ever ranked was a second degree.
So let me ask you,
cause you also do like an aggressive show,
you know,
as a comic do you get,
because
people know that about you.
Do you get fucked with like that know the people that come in with shows are so
fucking friendly.
I have no problems.
Everyone's so nice man.
We have a a friendly podcast.
It's a fun podcast,
you know,
and I do martial arts and I've started doing martial arts for two reasons.
One because I was picked on when I was younger and I didn't like it and I didn't
have an older brother and my stepfather was hardly ever around.
So I had a fight and I didn't like it.
I didn't like people fucking with me.
So I learned how to fight.
It was really that simple.
Then once I got really good at it,
I did it because I think martial arts is the most dangerous,
challenging and character building path for human development.
And I think to really know about yourself,
there's two ways you could go to war and you can find out about yourself
shooting people overseas,
fighting hand to hand combat and fucking ditch.
And stab a guy with a knife.
You can find out a lot about yourself in that situation.
Or you could travel around the country and fighting martial arts tournaments.
You can do that and you can find out an incredible amount about your tolerance
to pain.
You're willing to push through adversity.
That's what would get me nuts with you though.
That's what the joke was for me.
Because I know with martial arts they,
it's all the bind Dan body.
Yeah.
So when I would see you like lose it.
Oh yeah.
I'd be like,
isn't this guy supposed to be like zen?
You know when I'm starting it,
I'm bad at it for two,
two times,
one from drinking and someone's just talking shit and they're being aggressive.
I get,
they teach you to just say,
Oh,
I'm way better at it now.
Way better at it now.
But the,
the real problem I would always have two prompts in.
The biggest one was when I saw someone bullying someone,
that shit would drive me fucking crazy.
It drives me crazy when I see someone bullies.
You know what?
That's how I am too.
I was never like,
I fucking hate it.
You know?
It was never about like being being a bully.
It was just being able to protect myself and I would also hate when I saw people
get fucked with like that.
I understand where you're coming from that that was the,
the hot point,
the one store that you were talking about,
words screaming at this guy in front of the club.
He was threatening that he was going to kill one of the guys that worked there.
He was just,
they were kicking them out of the club because he was drunk and he was saying he
was gonna kick my ass and I didn't think anything of it.
But then I got off stage and my friends worried and he's in the front of the
club.
He's like,
that fucking guy still out here,
man.
He's saying he's gonna kill me.
He's saying he just got back from my rack and I just,
I just,
I just couldn't,
I saw red and I was like,
I'm going to beat this.
I saw you weren't going to hit him or anything,
but I just found that was trying to get them to hit me.
But,
but no,
I know that that's all I was trying to get that I just wanting to it that I was
there for them and see if I,
well,
that was totally different.
That was,
I didn't want to hurt.
No,
I know that.
But it was so beautiful because you were like,
if the mic was his nose,
you will right here.
It was so cool.
You know?
And everybody knew that when sia was a different case.
He's a guy who unfortunately has some sort of a psychological issue.
I don't know what it was,
but we had this guy that was around the comedy community that wasn't like
everybody else and he was,
he would literally go right on before you didn't do your best bed.
Say if you had a bit about a,
you know,
fucking hitting your computer with a hammer.
He would open with his version of your hitting the computer with a hammer bed.
I mean,
it was just,
he was,
it was aggressive in it.
It wasn't just that he was trying to do good for himself.
He was also trying to shut you down.
It's trying to step on your material.
It was a real,
real fucking big problem.
But even still then I never tried to hit that guy.
Never know.
I know.
I was there that night with the argument.
What was so crazy is Max that night,
it was like men see it like they advertise them that he's going to be performing
there.
So it's so impersonal.
That's a,
that's the,
yeah,
he comes up.
But I was there when it happened,
you know what I mean?
It was,
well,
every,
you know,
there's so many comics in the room that were backing me up.
I felt like I was representing them as much as though you was.
It was,
it was.
We were so sick and tired of it by that time,
you know?
And if it wasn't for,
uh,
you know,
Brian catching it on video,
that that guy probably would have pulled that off for another couple of years
and victimized a bunch of other guys and it ain't good for him either.
Man.
He's a talented performer.
You know what?
I do his own thing.
You know what I always told Max?
I go,
if you're truthful up there and write your own material,
you got to Korea.
You don't want it depend on other people to write immaterial.
So just use your mind and when you're on stage,
just let it go.
You know?
That's,
that's all you got to do.
And he's getting better and better at it.
And uh,
you know,
to specialty is going to do something else.
But you know,
did you talk to Joe about your dramas and all that?
I brought up the drums on the last day and you'll never
do a podcast sometime.
Like maybe play some songs or something.
No,
no.
But he'll be on the special,
he's going to do a huge thing on the drums because he's like untouchable dice,
podcast,
dices view on the world.
I would subscribe to it.
I guarantee you millions of people.
You'd probably have the number one podcast in the country.
I would,
I would tell people immediately,
go get it.
Yeah.
I don't know if I get the discipline to do this.
It's fucking easy.
Whenever you want a cigarette,
you drank a cup of coffee.
They just started talking shit about Chris Brown.
It's that simple.
You press record and you can have an engineer who come to your house and Max
always tells me,
you know what?
I should start the podcast and then just have my dad on it.
How about you two guys do a podcast together?
Brian,
we'll produce it and they'll put it out for you.
Just come here once,
twice a week or once a week?
Once every two weeks.
What do you do on the road though,
Ma on the road and I'll do anything.
I just promote my gigs though.
I don't you do radio anymore radio when they're my friends radio shows.
How do people know when you're going to be on on the podcast?
While the podcast is at least two or three times a week.
We do it.
We put it out on Twitter.
We tell people in advance,
you know,
hey,
Monday is going to be chill son in Tuesday's going to be Michael Rupert.
That's the schedule for next week.
And if they miss it,
they can download it on iTunes.
And one of the things I was thinking that you should do,
cause I know that a Ford Fairlane doesn't have a DVD commentary and it would be
really funny if you just did a podcast
watching Ford Fairlane so people at home could hit start at the same time.
And you're just talking about the movie.
They asked me,
I wouldn't do the commentary for it.
Whatever.
You did it though.
No,
but I'm saying why?
Because this was a movie that could have gone through the roof and they pulled
in in a week and it was doing big numbers and because of what happened with Fox
20th Century Fox put it out,
they,
they played the movie for a week.
I had to go see it on Hollywood boulevard.
That's how I saw afford fairly.
So it was doing really well and they pulled the chest that time.
You got to understand this thing came out in 1990 so you know,
an opening weekend for that movie today would be like,
you know,
$45 million.
You know,
back then it was like an $18 million opening weekend cause you know the price it
costs to go into a movie theater and it got this big hit even though they didn't
do the premia.
And then they pulled it in a week.
And what happened with that movie is then they added all around the world.
So they made a ton of money with it.
Then at that time there were no DVDs.
It was just tapes.
It was just videotapes.
And the month that it came out for,
you know how years ago,
uh,
it was like $2 to rent the tape.
But if you kept the tape,
it was like a hundred dollars.
The first month that came out,
they sold at the hundred dollar price.
400,000 units.
Wow.
So it was like,
by the time they called me years later to do commentary,
I was like,
you know what?
You pulled my movie out of the theater is why would I do commentary about it?
You know what I mean?
I didn't care.
Yeah,
no,
I could see it from that point of view.
From a fan's point of view.
People would love it,
especially if he did it for yourself instead.
We always still talk about a sequel to it because it has the audience.
It always had the order.
You do a podcast,
I guarantee you how many people would watch that fucking thing with with you
doing it by failing,
you'll give me all your information.
Would you be able to play legally play for talk over it.
You don't even have to.
You just like it because what you're doing to watch it at home,
you just have it in the background playing,
so like,
oh,
I see,
so you get people to press play and watch the movie at the same time so they
have his commentary on the laptop or something.
Yeah,
exactly.
Absolutely.
That's ultra crowd.
Tell you one thing.
I had a blast and we've done it all.
We do it with the UFC drunk castle.
Oh,
that's right,
that's right.
I had a blessed stow in that movie.
I'll tell you that much.
That was a fun movie to date.
By the way,
Brian,
before I say anything,
there's a UFC coming up soon and we should do that because I'm not doing it.
It's one of those FX shows.
Let's do a draw the Australia one.
No it's not Australia.
Um,
let me find out what the card is.
I think they think it's soon.
I think it's like Tuesday.
Let's do it.
I think it's next Tuesday in high school.
That was my favorite movie ever.
And I had your poster above for the movie above my bed.
Cause I used to work at a movie theater and one of my favorite shit was like,
just the ridiculousness of it.
Like when you fell off the building,
like my hair,
my hair,
it's like this silly shit.
I would quote quote,
you have my most of my life,
they let me do
my thing in the movie.
It was a fun movie to do.
I thought it was a great movie,
but you know,
with,
with everything surrounding it,
it wasn't fun.
Yeah.
You know,
even like,
you know,
they had me go on a Saturday night live before the movie came out and you know,
that everybody was walking off the show.
You know,
I don't even want to say it,
stupid girls name and uh,
you know,
it just started like nothing I got to do was a pleasant experience,
so,
you know,
that's,
but that was then,
you know,
and the,
and the beauty of being around today and still doing what I do is that I
survived all that stuff.
You know,
cause a lot of people would have followed it.
I don't fall for anything.
I always,
I always just keep going,
you know,
and I always find the way back one way or another when we were talking about
like the period where you had nothing going on until entourage puts you back on
again.
You know,
did you try some stuff that didn't work or did you like,
I did a reality show about seven years ago and you know with all these tapes,
you know these producers at Fox TV,
they saw my tapes and they said this is a show,
you know,
so they sold it to VH one and then when,
and the way I would fill myself is that it could be cut together and they got
picked up for seven shows and I said,
why don't you guys just take these tapes and cut it together?
But they had a budget,
they had a,
it was like they got like 315 grand an episode and I said,
all you need is editors,
you know,
and I'll do some voice of,
I go,
you have the show.
I have filmed my life,
you know,
I was filming heaven,
which you saw me do that all the time,
you know?
And they go,
no,
we have ideas.
And as they're shooting these ideas,
even my kids were like,
what are they doing?
And they came over with this episode,
a rough cut,
what they called the image episode and you know,
they put like a grill in my mouth and dressed me like a rapper and I hated it.
I hated it.
I was young and I forgot if it was either Max a Dylan that looked at the
producers and said,
if you were doing a show would axl rose,
wouldn't you just let them be axle?
So why don't you just let dice be dice instead of making up all this bullshit.
I just remembered you were in foolish.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
One of my favorite crazy Eddie Griffin movies,
Eddie Griffin in full prime.
Crazy for him.
Those are a about,
he played a comic named foolish ways.
You were like the club owner,
right?
Yeah,
Eddie Griffin.
Man.
There was,
there was a kid who had some fucking talent.
there was moments where that kid would be on stage just crushing.
Like I,
I thought Eddie Griffin at one point in time was going to be one of the biggest
acts like ever in the country.
I thought Eddie Griffin,
you know,
I sort of found that a,
and you found him?
Well what happened was I was at the comedy store one night and he walks over to
me and he goes,
I'm going to open for you one day.
And you know,
I know we talked for two minutes and then a couple weeks later I was getting
ready to go on tour and I already had opening acts and Eddie was on stage and he
had like,
you know,
2% material.
But what he had,
he was exciting to watch,
you know what I mean?
So he came offstage and I said,
you know,
come over here,
I said,
you know what,
I saw you on stage tonight and I said,
you really do have that potential,
you're going to be great.
I said,
so why don't you go pack your bags and we leave in the morning.
It was the dice rule store,
you know.
And the next thing you know,
we're in Philadelphia.
I'm doing,
I was going to do I think two nights at the spectrum and you know,
I see that he doesn't have a coat,
no socks and the snow on the ground.
I go,
where's all your stuff?
He goes,
I don't have anything.
So next thing you know,
we're on a shopping spree and he gives me the nickname,
uncle dice to this day.
You know,
cause I just saw him in Vegas last week and yeah,
I bought them all these clothes and he did a lot of that tour with me.
Was He in the movie?
He was in dice rolls,
is seen in dice rolls and he was great.
You know,
he had to do,
is take where he's yelling at me in a gas station.
I was like doing,
you know,
before it turned into dice,
I'm doing like my own version of like a nerd.
But I was really doing my impersonation of Max,
who was a baby at the time,
you know,
and you know,
Eddie Griffin screaming at me in a,
in a,
in a gas station,
she rips off like with the,
uh,
the,
the windshield wiper.
It's gone.
Motherfuck is like,
Yo,
it's just taking them away from a black man.
And I'm sitting there going,
yeah,
they Kiki,
you know,
and you got to say what mother fucker.
And then he gets in the car and he's screaming at me and he was great.
He was great.
Big Low.
He can act as fuck Eddie's,
Eddie's got a lot of talent,
a lot of talent,
a lot of crazy,
a lot of talent.
But he'll admit to that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's the twice fun to be around.
He's a great guy,
you know,
but you know,
he,
he is a great,
a great talent.
You know,
and you know,
at that time he'd come onstage twirling of Bhutan with a big top hat top hat,
you know,
making the crowd going,
uh,
hey motherfucker.
Hey motherfucker.
Hey.
And then he didn't know what he was going to do once the music stop,
you know,
but he had a couple of bits and,
and he would kill the crowd.
He did great.
He's a great performer.
And I remember his first special that he did and say he did.
I think he did an HBO half hour and uh,
he was like,
he had shorts on.
Yeah.
That's where he would do to Michael Jackson and prince and Gus.
Was it a half an hour?
I don't know if that was a half hour.
You're talking about the one where he's wearing like the big yellow.
Yeah,
that was good.
That was strong.
Fucking strong.
And then I did try to train him for another special,
like a one hour HB out thing and he didn't listen.
You know what I mean?
Cause I said first we trained physically,
then we train.
Oh,
you
want to work out with them?
Yeah.
So,
so he went up the mountain,
he went up this mountain with me and he goes right after the mountain,
we're going to go to the gym,
you know,
and then halfway up the mountain,
he's like,
fuck this.
And then the next day when I'm calling him,
you know,
he's not even returning the call.
There he is right there.
He's a hell of a can they hear him?
He can make
the falls.
Didn't do it yesterday and a nose camera couldn't shut the shit off quick
enough.
You could see what the motherfucker was thanking.
His brain's hit the ground.
I said,
look at him.
He was begging about killing himself yet did dumb motherfucker.
Y'All saying what?
Only white people do shit and shit like that.
You know they have problems and shit and they flip.
You got the camera man in the background.
Great job director and they can fuck it.
You're fired but a stupid shot.
That's the stupidest shot I've ever seen.
Any of the comedy special.
I talk about a shot that brings you away from the special.
See a guy with a fucking heads and on a camera behind them.
That's so stupid.
They have a shot of the audience that could have used their hand away.
The shit of it.
Look at what's making you mad today.
This is the first moment of you like getting heated up.
You want to hurt that guy?
I want to hurt them.
Show director.
I want to talk to the director.
The Violin Day.
Did you see the new Avengers?
Maybe Joe did you like?
It was fucking amazing when the hug grabs that,
that guy had smashes them into the ground.
Me,
I didn't see the movie.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
I won't say anymore,
but it's fucking tremendous.
The Hawk is amazing.
Yeah,
man.
They got to do a new hulk movie.
And what's the guy's name that plays the hawk?
What's the actors?
I don't know his name.
I still can't get this.
Can't get past how friendly your audiences are.
Oh,
they're the nicest audiences ever.
They're super friendly.
Yeah.
You got bizarre.
But I,
I'm a nice guy still.
You know?
I know you were a nice guy,
but when you're doing your stage thing,
I've seen it enough times to know because my audience is the most aggressive
audience I've ever seen from anybody mean.
I'm not even talking about comics.
I'm talking even rock shows.
Yeah,
they're there.
They're there to go nuts.
You know?
Did they had to go crazy?
That's why it's about controlling the crowd.
Half of it,
my dad's audience,
the only audience that ever heckles me.
I never get heckled anywhere.
People are always cool.
Whenever I opened for my dad,
I know I have to do with dirty your set and he has to attend a more hardcore set
and just the hardcore,
this is just out of respect.
The actor's name is Mark Rufallo.
That's the guy who plays the Hawk fucking tremendous actor.
Yeah,
I would imagine you have pretty aggressive crowds.
The once an event's going to see a dice show is not just going to see a regular
comedy show like the,
this tossed around in the must be pretty intense.
It's insanity.
It's like he's leading an angry mob of people.
It's not even like about laughter.
Tell,
tell him,
tell him I was playing this set for him because like I said,
I'm going around the country testing everything and uh,
I was playing the set from,
I just did the Burgin Center in Jersey and so we sat down late at night to
listen to this set for a few minutes and we shut it off.
And Mexico's,
now I know why the government and everybody else had a problem with you.
He goes,
it sounds like this angry mob.
And it would be scary to government,
you know,
because of what he's saying and the way they're reacting to it anyway.
That's why government officials can be like,
I don't know what this,
and it's the dumbest Shit I could think of.
I mean some of it that there is no thought that goes into it.
Um,
as far as,
you know,
certain bits,
like I don't do my homework as well.
I just want to do the bit in the funniest way I can.
I don't care if it's,
if it's got any kind of truth to it.
Sometimes,
you know,
it's just gotta be,
there are certain bits that are truthful,
but certain bits I'm doing just to affect them and make them laugh their balls
off.
That when I see a guy banging his fists on the stage and his head's laying on
the stage that he can laugh anymore,
I know I'm doing my job,
you know,
that,
that's how I look at that and I come off and I go,
did you see them?
You know,
and as great as the crowds might be in Vegas,
it's,
it's the road crowds that are really insane because Vegas,
there's a lot of things that come into it from gambling to drinking too.
You know,
fighting with your wife,
have a,
losing the money.
Yeah,
it was tense.
But when you come to a concert on the road,
they're coming just for that.
So I could really drive them.
I want them to leave.
They're going,
I've never seen anything like that or witnessed that.
And the crowd is half of it.
You know,
when I do this thing about,
you know,
that I've been doing for years where,
um,
where I pick on a guy in the crowd and you know,
then I turn it around and go,
but look what we've been through,
Eh,
now me and you were fucking friends,
right?
You know,
fucking best.
I want to take my glass.
I want to toast you.
I go,
no,
I want everybody to raise their glasses to this guy.
And the Max goes,
you should make them get up.
So I'm in Vegas last time cycle,
forget about raising everybody.
Get the fuck up,
you know,
get up for this man.
Some just guys sitting there and I go,
so I want to say to you right now,
he is to yo and then everybody go suck in my deck.
Oh,
you know,
he's just the most ridiculous stuff,
you know?
And it's just so enjoyable for me because I go,
they've gotten
to leave their life for an hour.
Right.
Cause you know,
I might,
I might say,
you know,
I hate going up there some nights,
but once I'm out there,
I just,
that's my freedom to just go nuts.
You know?
I'll even tell the crowd,
like,
you know why I'm up here right now?
Because sometimes I get into a fight with Eleanor on the stage I go,
because she just went to Tom.
My wife would happen here and when I come off this stage,
they're both going to let me fucking have it.
So I'm just going to hang out here with you for a little more.
You know what I mean?
I used to sit in the back of the comedy store,
uh,
where that,
back porches,
you know,
there's the,
there's the steps where Joey Diaz,
who's always just smokes cigarettes,
the steps where the belly room is.
And we could be back there and a dice,
be on stage,
your dad would be onstage and all of a sudden we would just hear screaming,
just screaming,
you fucking dummy you dumb fucking Tommy Dom.
And we were oh mean dices up mean dice up.
But we run in the back dice meat in the back and we would sit and watch you
torture people.
You've had some of the,
my,
the funniest brutalization of people I've ever,
and there's not even like,
there's a bunch of people dealing with hecklers that are on,
on the Internet.
I don't think there's any of you,
any of you have those like comedy store sets.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't even know.
But uh,
it can cause so less time we're in Vegas.
Um,
you know,
obviously Max is single and he's out there looking for girls.
So can we tell him?
Uh,
sure.
Yeah.
Well,
I'll start it.
You could finish it.
So this is,
but I just want to preface this by saying the story I told last time,
that Alyssa,
the thing,
now this story blows that story away.
Okay.
That's how you should possibly,
you learn well from your father.
It's so much harder now.
Strong and then build up.
Well,
well this is the thing.
So there's this girl in the front and she's a 10,
you know,
and she's alone.
A blind girl just,
you know,
10 from head to toe,
with the big tits are nice,
big fat.
It's the right package.
So I'm talking to her,
you know about what she does.
She's a Dominatrix,
uh,
the way she put it.
She said she's in the fetish industry.
She goes,
I'm in the fetish world,
you know,
and uh,
I go,
how all of these,
she's only 21 years old,
you know,
and uh,
so I go 21.
I go,
you're like young guys,
you know,
she's going,
yes.
So,
so now I'm mad at the show.
Cause now it's all about getting Max hooked up and gone.
Max.
I think I got one for you here.
Okay,
so the next thing you know,
here comes Max with the girl after the show backstage to get the picture.
What would ha I'm some off the stage when he's talking to her.
I don't know what she looks like.
All I know is he's going,
you know,
I have a son,
you should meet him.
I didn't say I have a son.
I go,
he was up here,
you know,
a half hour ago,
whatever.
So I'm like,
I gotta meet this girl,
but I don't know what looks like.
So I run out,
hang out near the tee shirt rack and you know,
meet this girl when everyone comes out.
And um,
so I see this,
she's literally the last person out of the place because she was right in the
front row.
Yeah,
she went to the bathroom or something.
She's the last person,
Eleanor Eleanor.
She brings a,
the girl out to me and I'm like,
Hey,
what's up?
Yeah.
You know,
I'm like,
you remember I was on,
he was talking about me.
So
I'm like,
all right,
you know,
you want to get a drink or whatever,
you should write cards.
So at first it was,
first it was,
I want to get a picture so he comes back.
But what's funny is,
you know,
you got to tell Joe what you tell people that want to meet me.
You know,
cause he's always out there after the show with my wife and Eleanor.
You know how you tell them like he's not like you're not great.
So,
but how you kind of have to let people know before it's,
I don't like,
I don't like meeting people.
No,
I don't.
I'm not a,
I'm not.
No.
And the reason is because a lot of these guys or come back stage and not try to
put me like in a headlock and I get physical about it.
You know,
I'm not going to lie to you and it's not about being tough for anything.
Oh yeah.
It was this one guy,
this was a couple months ago.
I thought I was going to break his own when he did that because I just react.
I don't like to say take your hands off me.
I react to it,
you know?
And a lot of these guys that are a lot bigger than me,
right.
But when I'm in that frame of mind,
you don't see it.
It's like,
don't fucking put your hands on me cause I'll break your shoulder.
You know?
So he knows not to bring people back.
No papers.
I hate people,
no people.
You know,
99% of people,
we just tell them that,
you know,
but he's,
no,
he left.
But they ask him like,
why can't I meet him?
Right.
Am I just can't,
you know,
take you back there because he's just not great socially.
I tried to let them know like,
you're not going to get the experience that you want.
Like it's awesome to watch the show.
But if you meet him,
you're probably going to,
I don't know,
you're not going to be.
So my favorite things you did,
I don't know if you want to talk about this,
but one of my favorite things you did is you started taking less and less shirts
with you when you would go to shows.
Oh yeah,
I heard about this.
What do you mean?
Well,
you shirts are the ones we sell.
Oh,
that was last time we went to auctions.
What I decided is what do I get to bring a hundred shirts when I could bring 10
you know,
and just have,
Mike Black was the opener back then.
And my kids were with me on the road.
So Mike Black was the barker,
the auctioneer,
you know.
And we would,
you know,
sell the shirts.
He would start like at $150 you know,
and you know,
and we were selling shirts for like between anywhere from one 50 to $500 a
shirt,
you know,
and you know,
and of course with dad I would take a picture and sign the show,
whatever.
But what was funny is my son Dylan at the time was 12 and he's taken the money,
you know,
and making the change with Max who was a
15,
you know?
And like that was my crew like flack and these two little kids.
So from the time you were like 11,
you were watching them do standup?
I wouldn't really,
uh,
okay.
Well the first time I ever really saw my dad do standup was in 2000 when I was
10 because my dad went back to Madison Square Garden.
What did,
this is an inch.
I got to tell you this story.
I thought there's a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of good stories.
Is there an ending on this?
Alright.
So,
um,
that's a problem and a lot of shows,
right?
You worry about running out of time.
Well,
I also want to keep it interesting for you.
This is very interesting.
So,
you know,
since my kids were born,
I always thought about like,
how do I explain what would I do as their father?
You know?
And plus they can't really see it.
Right.
You know.
So from an early age,
like I groom them into the business,
like understanding,
you know,
what I do and sort of how big it was,
but it's not that big of a deal to me because I'm daddy.
You know what I mean?
When they were kids,
so now max was 10 and Dylan was six and at that time,
this was the a 2000 and I had nothing going on.
I didn't have any TV shows or specials.
So I decided,
I started doing a opie and Anthony W on,
uh,
in the afternoons.
And at that time I was in a war with Howard Stern.
We weren't talking and they were the same.
They were the same network,
you know,
so I didn't give a fuck.
I would go on their show and they were pretty new at it.
And the audience started building pretty rapidly between them and May.
And I would call in three days a week,
or if I was in New York,
I'd go in.
And that was always drama.
I had like this huge fucking thing happened with Jay Moore that he was calling
to.
Yeah.
But,
but I,
I don't want to go fucking single comment that hasn't had a problem with that.
Not saying it was a simple thing,
what happened?
Don't make me go into that.
But it was a simple thing that he could have said.
He was sorry,
I haven't had a problem with it,
but what he wanted to be a tough guy over the air.
And I was in La Really,
you know,
and he goes,
hey dice,
I'm not afraid of you.
What happened is he went like on Letterman and did like a very close thing of
Pachino to mine.
So when we were on the air,
I said,
you know,
Jay,
I go,
you did my pachino thing on Letterman.
And he started in rather than go,
oh,
well,
you know,
it was like,
no,
it wasn't him.
It was Conan.
And I said,
well,
that's my thing.
You know what I mean?
It's my bit,
and,
and he got,
I forgot how it got out of control,
but then he got into like the tug,
you know,
I'm from Jersey,
I'm not afraid of you.
I go,
okay.
We tended a little,
little bit of Jay more impression.
You've got a little bit of a j more impression.
Do I?
When I do it was,
it was a huge fight because,
hey,
what'd he say to you?
Well now I'm thinking about it,
but he goes,
well,
I'm not afraid of you.
You know,
I'm from Jersey.
And I go,
look Jay,
it's not about that.
It's about being tough and I'm really fucking tough.
Okay.
I go,
there aren't too many guys that scare me.
No,
but from,
but you got to understand,
you know,
I was putting a hospital a bunch of times when I was a kid.
I've had my nose busted,
my head split open,
my face split up and you know,
so I know what it is to lose.
Like when you lost your first fight,
you weren't afraid to fight again cause you know what it is to get hit right.
You know what I mean?
So the last person on earth that's going to frighten me is a guy with a beige
sweater and his sleeves rolled up.
Jay Moore.
It doesn't scare me at all.
But if you're going to tell me in front of millions of people,
you're not afraid of me.
Well now you got a problem,
you're not going to be able to fucking handle.
So I told them over the year,
I can remember you telling me this because now when you get back to La,
you better come to find me at the comedy store because if I got to come and look
for you,
it's going to be even fucking worse.
I'm warning you.
So what happens is after I get off the air,
a Ralphie may calls me because he had my phone number and he goes,
you know,
Jay was just fucking around.
Go,
you're not involved in this.
I got the guy opened his mouth.
He in fucking apologized to me.
I go,
and now you know he's going to have a problem.
If he don't come look for me,
I'll look for him.
It's that simple that his wife even called me.
They all of a sudden I get a call from a detective.
I thought it was a joke.
It was at night.
Is this Andrew Clay?
Just Annette?
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
well,
uh,
I'm actually a fan.
He goes,
I can't believe I'm calling you,
but we had a complaint this,
uh,
and he went to the police station,
like what?
His wife at the time.
And the cop was even telling me,
I,
it felt more like a domestic dispute and anything else.
And I said,
we're having a radio fight.
We were arguing on,
on the opiate and Anthony and we wound up making up whatever,
wait a minute,
wait and wait and wait and wait.
He wears the fucking police.
In fact,
like I come basic dispute.
Yeah.
That was between him and his wife.
I don't,
you know,
well,
what happened?
He made like a jewel reference to me and that's when I snapped out,
you know,
uh,
on the,
on the radio and even the New York Post wrote it.
It was one of the only times I got protected,
you know,
but you know,
they wrote up what he,
he said that was very wrong.
And I'm a little Larry.
This is the fucking news.
Oh,
Jay Morrison,
a Jew joke.
When you put your,
but you're getting,
you're getting me off.
What happened with the garden?
What happened?
It's a beautiful story,
but at that time know I was doing,
I was back to clubs,
you know my agents do that.
So I decided that instead of telling my kids about my history,
I want to show them one,
I want to do an arena that I knew there were young,
but at least they would have that picture in their heads,
something in years to come.
That's how I really looked at it would click in their minds that they didn't
just hear about their father.
They got to see it,
you know,
in that big of a place.
So I decided to do an album.
I put the album out the first day it's out.
My agent calls me up and he goes,
what do you think the move is?
And I go,
I say,
you should book the garden.
And he goes,
book the garden.
He goes,
last time you did Westbury,
you did half a house.
Now explain to the people listening.
The different Westbury sold out is about 3000 seats.
So if I did half a house,
1500 seats,
so why would I be thinking I could be at Madison Square Garden now?
You know what I mean?
Cause I hadn't done arenas in a,
in a bunch of years.
So I go,
I'm telling you,
Dennis,
I've been doing this,
this radio show,
you know,
in New York,
opie and Anthony.
He goes,
so based off a radio show you're doing,
you think you're selling the garden?
He goes,
why don't we do the beacon theater?
I go,
I'll solve the beacon in 20 minutes,
which the beacons like 3,500 seats.
He goes,
well,
if you sell it in 20 minutes,
we could always move it to the garden because there's no way.
He didn't think any way possible.
You know that I'm going to sell the beacon in 20 minutes.
Bottom line,
I'm telling you the story short,
I saw it a beacon out in 35 minutes.
So my agent calls me up and he goes,
I don't get it.
But obviously there's something,
you know and,
and I don't.
So Ron Delzner,
who did my first arena with me,
he's a very famous promoter.
He works under the umbrella now have a live nation.
He said the same thing to my agent.
He goes,
obviously dice know something we don't.
So they per 10,000 seats on sale at the garden.
Okay.
The first day we do 7,000 seats,
which if I didn't have to do the beacon,
the beacon was on the 20th of October,
2000 and the garden was now going to be on the 26th not even a week later.
Holy Shy.
So 7,000 seats and now the ticket sales slow down because the subway series was
announced,
the Yankees and the mets.
So ticket sales slow down.
But the bottom line of what happened is the day of the garden,
I get a call.
The reason I even stopped doing arenas,
I would get claustrophobic from the whole thing being sold and people around me,
so I couldn't take anymore.
So I get a call from my agent knowing if delzner could open up the back,
which was incredible because it was going to be the last night of the world
series,
the Yankees playing the mets and we did 13,000 people at the garden that night.
Max was allowed to watch as much of the show as he,
he knew when I would start getting too filthy leave,
leave that part of the arena and then come back and when it's not that bad.
You know what I mean?
You know cause its 11 Max,
I was like 10 he was 10 years old.
What was the feeling that you had when you watched your dad go up there in front
of 13,000 screaming animals?
What was that like when you realized the of,
I mean what was the realization?
Well,
I guess the way I thought about it at that time,
I just thought it was really cool and I was just 10 years old and the language
didn't really faze me because even at that age I knew it was just a joke because
my dad was never like that with me when he was offstage.
I just knew all right,
when my dad goes on stage,
he's like that when he comes off,
he's somewhat normal,
you know?
Yeah.
So I'm just,
as I just saw it as a 10 year old kid just thinking,
whoa,
that's just so cool that my dad is doing that and that there's all these people
here and I wasn't thinking in terms of what,
what this means to stand up and what my dad has done.
And I didn't have that mindset at the time.
I just thought it was awesome.
Yeah.
And my whole thing was,
like I told you,
I always teach my kids by example.
I wanted to show them that with hard work and with belief,
and with that drive that that that's built into you,
that you could accomplish anything you want to accomplish.
That's always been,
you know,
when,
when I do certain things and people talk to me,
like you made all these millions and then you lost it and went through divorce
and you gambled and you bought shit.
I go,
it's never been about money to me.
Like,
oh,
I could always make it.
Yeah,
making money again now.
But the point is that,
you know,
it's what you do with your life,
what you could accomplish with your life.
And I didn't really know starting out what it would become when I made it.
You know,
you're never prepared for what fame brains,
but I know like even when I saw rocky one with my father in Brooklyn,
when I left that theater,
I told my father I was 16 years old.
I said,
I'm going to do that with my life.
And my father goes,
what?
You're going to become a boxer,
you know?
And I go,
no,
I'm going to,
I have that thing in me where I could really accomplish with my own life.
I'm just not sure how I'm going to go about it yet.
And,
and that's what it's always been to four for me,
it's always been like reach your highest potential and what you do,
give the very best and show people what you got to,
to offer them.
And I always think of myself and I know my history,
you know,
and I know you know that,
that,
I mean,
I don't know who the guy,
I'll come around that tea,
you know,
I did the rose bowl with guns and roses,
I did things like that.
You know,
it takes a certain person in my mind that God puts here at a certain time to do
these different things.
And I always felt like I was born when I was born to do exactly what I'm doing
now and that that's how it is for me.
And you know where I believe if you believe something like that,
if you truly believe something like that,
it's incredibly empowering and it becomes real.
Oh please.
You can become real.
When I used to come off at the comedy store to win the morning.
You know when there's four people and you know the s whole Karmic,
whoever it would be wearing a thin coat,
too good.
I'd look at that guy and go,
I'm the biggest in the world.
They just don't know it yet.
And this is when I was a struggling comic and that's what comics can handle with
me.
It was the,
the real part of who I am,
forget about on stage,
the jokes,
everything was this unbelievable confidence that I was given,
you know?
And it's always been inside me like just a complete belief in I could conquer
whatever I have to conquer.
That's completely different than most comedians.
Yeah.
Most comics,
if you think of comics years ago,
I mean,
you know,
I'm the affair or anything,
but you're a nice looking guy.
I'm a nice looking guy.
My son's Nice,
what I'm saying could comics years ago,
think of what Buddy Hackett look like that guide him.
Walk around and look in the mirror and go,
I could bang anything I want.
You know what I mean?
[inaudible] were goofy looking fucking guys.
I think it comes to the point where you can't really define comedy.
It's either comedy or it's not comedy.
And there's a fucking billion different examples.
There's Mitch Hedberg,
there's you,
there's,
there's a million different answers.
And that's why I never understood why comics had no comradery between them
because everybody's just an individual.
You know,
everybody,
you know,
there were guys that do prop come and that's why I hate when guys pick on carrot
topic cause I go guy could own fucking Las Vegas.
Okay.
He's cooking and he always seems like a nice guy.
He's one of the nicest guys you'd ever meet.
Carrot top and seems real friendly.
Yeah.
And I did fine.
I did this fucking roast for,
uh,
for kiss for Gene Simmons and I'm downstairs waiting to go on and Gene Simmons
didn't even know I'm going to do the roast.
I came from the front doors and uh,
and a all picking on fucking carrot top.
And I came up to annihilate these fucking guys for doing that,
you know?
And when I got the carrot top,
he thought I was going to destroy him,
you know?
And I said,
and your rule is sitting here and you're picking on fucking carrot top.
And he gave me like 20 calls it,
that is because I was like,
it was,
it was the bully effect.
They will bullying this guy.
And I was like,
I could shred anyone at this,
this fucking guy that hosts the show,
this ugly motherfucker who is a Ross.
Jeff.
Yeah.
Jeff Ross.
This fucking little piece of come that came from his dad's day.
Whoa.
You know?
Well,
no,
the guy,
the guy introduced,
remember from the Eighties Andrew dice clay in the mean.
That's what he said.
That's how I guess now.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
It's like did his day.
Who the fuck even knows him?
You know,
he's just this little fucking roly poly cock sucker,
you know,
date,
gate,
clean,
fucking lick the fucking dirt from under my toenails.
You know what I mean?
There's a visual.
Yeah,
well that's what he is in my mind.
Well,
you know,
Jeff's things,
the roastmaster
as whole human beings.
There's nothing better than that Brooklyn version of asshole.
He's in Aa,
so it's an ace or symbols,
a fucking air.
So you understand I'm not calling him and I'm saying he's got an s whole face.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So what I'm saying is he's got to face that on a lot of levels.
Resembles a fucking asshole.
It's always been a nice guy to me.
Oh,
fuck breeds.
Anybody looking to knock me down.
You know,
they're getting knocked down when I was fucking where we breathe.
It's unnecessary.
And uh,
and first of all,
you gotta,
I mean,
Nice Guy,
I guess.
You know,
I got nothing against him.
He's just,
you want to open your mouth about me.
You've got an enemy for life and when you don't want,
why are you in the meets with opie right now?
Are you still in?
I thought that was
dem from was what?
Max was a kid.
And I was,
and I was going to do the garden,
you know,
um,
Max was in the studio and they had a problem with this.
Uh,
a talk show guy,
man,
cow to Chicago and they were pressing the issue and I didn't even know what
happened.
And I was like looking at Opi like endless,
you know what I mean?
My kids he yet,
you know,
and he didn't end it and uh,
and we became enemies for a little while,
but we met up.
That's cool.
They're good guys.
We have a good time.
Max,
you were coming out.
She was the last one out of the,
the audience that dominate trick sticks that we are at.
[inaudible] I talk about anything on then fucking box.
How did we even get,
that's a weird term.
Thank God Brian was here to bring this up.
So what happened?
Okay,
so after the,
after the show rather.
Okay.
So I meet her at the tee shirt stand,
bring up backstage and this is the kid that tells the young man,
I should say to tells everybody it's impossible.
He's not good with people.
But the minute as a girl he had comes Max,
which I loved.
And my dad was really cool with her,
super friendly because he knew he knew what I was going for.
So new to what you know,
be cool.
So they take the picture,
we get out of there,
go downstairs and then here comes my wife,
you know,
the Latino wife with Eleanor and I'm going,
Oh,
this is my wife Valerie.
You know,
we don't want anyone getting into,
we don't want anybody getting the wrong idea.
Like she's back there for me,
you know?
Right.
Okay.
I'm not going to give every detail.
No,
you don't have.
So we go downstairs,
have a couple of days.
We ended up having some more drinks than I really thought we were going to have.
You have like four piece or whatever.
And um,
I'm not even sure how to tell basically the next day when he was the greatest
night of my life.
That's the only way to say it.
It was single handedly the greatest night
of my life.
Any peacock feathers,
any dominatrix stuff involved or because it's what she does,
she was just so relaxed and open about anything sexually that it just made me
completely relaxed and feel completely at ease because it's what she does.
It's her job.
When she came back stage,
I had a question her a little because you know,
I still got to look out for him,
you know,
so I'm like asking her like what she does and you sent me the text message
telling me about different things I do smoking fetish.
I go,
what's his smoking?
She goes,
guys,
they'll just come in a just smoke cigarettes around them and act tough.
Whoa.
You know,
crazy shit.
You know?
But you wind up dating this girl.
It was fun.
When I went down to the bar,
I got a text from my dad in all capitals because my dad likes to text and all
capitals.
So it always sounds like how cause I got a problem with my left dies so I don't
see the phone is good.
And uh,
it was like day
in the hotel.
Don't give her any money and have fun.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
Look caps.
Joe,
Joe.
Joe Changes the,
uh,
the screen size actually.
So I nearly texts Joe nearly texted to you yesterday that I texted in capital
letters because of my aunt.
Oh,
you do all caps also?
No,
no,
no.
That's his,
that's what I,
uh,
I made the text larger so I can see it.
It's any options,
you know,
he sounds like he's scaling through the text message.
Oh,
I don't know.
How do you have an iPhone?
No,
I don't believe in 2012.
You shouldn't look into one of those.
They exist,
I swear.
Awesome.
What do you believe in?
You don't believe in Iphone,
but it's really rarely,
but it's real,
but it's really,
I have two of them.
I just don't believe in him.
I think it's still much,
they're like the upper cons.
What is it about a that you don't believe in them too much?
How much do I need to do with,
you know what I mean?
I Dunno.
For me,
um,
I'm a,
I'm a technological junkie.
I love,
my wife has the iPhone we use for the Twitter and everything.
Okay.
You know,
I use command though.
Do you tell her what to do?
And she does it for you.
Come in.
And though I love the fanny pack.
That's actually a very nice one.
Where'd you get that roots?
Roots.
The roots as the best ones.
Oh,
look at this.
I'm making a note right now.
Roots Fanny Pack.
I just love fellow fanny pack users.
This is commando is he's uh,
just to sum up the rest of the story real quick for all of the lessons that you
could fall in the ground and it's just that like a super 300 feet underwater.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Well that's smart.
I like if you having a fight with somebody from the beach,
you go on the water and you could call it.
Yeah.
It's like,
why does it need to go on the ward?
What am I doing on the ward?
I got to text somebody while I'm swimming.
Right.
You really fucking call someone underwater.
That's amazing.
It's a crazy fun.
I love it though.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of those they're making now I nickname [inaudible] style.
That's what this is.
Yeah.
They make those tough books to Panasonic makes those,
so my brother in law's a navy seal.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Okay.
He's the real deal.
So does he have like that kind of computer that got everything?
You could just fucking the ocean man though.
Wow.
He doesn't even have that.
It doesn't even have,
does you have an iPhone?
I love when people,
when people show you their phone and go,
you can't even get this echo.
Well how the fuck did you get from NASA?
Who the fuck you,
but what you can get today,
that's what people do with their,
with their electronics.
So you can't get well,
who the fuck you got to know to get this.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm telling you,
I do a whole thing on it now.
I can't with the technology,
like you know when you go to parties it's all they talk about,
you know,
instead of what a party should be.
Fucking the ugly guy or girl on everybody's jackets.
You know what I mean?
That's a party.
I remember that you move your jacket out of the pile and go,
yeah,
come in here.
That was the nice dark room come here,
chubby.
It was coming pockets.
First thing I would do when I go to a party years ago when I was like 17,
18,
you spot the ugly girl in the corner.
Gonnar and if that don't work out,
she'll still be there.
Nothing like a fat girl.
I taught the Max all the time.
What else happened?
Did anything else happen to the dominatrix?
The best way to search?
Actually,
you know what?
You can explain what happened with the,
uh,
with the condoms.
Oh,
this is a really cool story.
I hope so anyways,
cause when I think about it's cool,
but let's see how it comes out.
How old are you Max?
I'm 21 so I didn't have any condoms on me and I figured she would because of
what?
She knows.
Jesus,
everything's just about to go down.
And this is after,
you know,
we go to the hotel room,
I play her my rock bands,
music,
which there's really nothing better to do with a girl then play her your own
bay.
I don't like an iPod or whatever.
So she's really into the music.
Everything's about to go down and we don't have any condoms.
So she starts going,
you know,
I feel everything happens for a reason.
Maybe we're not supposed to get together.
And I go into a panic because I'm like,
there's no way we're in the bed.
It has to go down.
There's no way this is not happening.
She goes to the bathroom,
I pick up the phone,
call the operator,
I'm like,
can we get some condoms up to room 52 45 please?
And they send that liver at condom.
They send up like this classic bellman like 50 something years old,
full head of solid gray gives me the condoms.
I give them the money and uh,
I didn't know they would do that and see,
I would be the guy running out in the lobby trying to get a towel take from,
I didn't know.
They didn't know.
He knew if he left the game.
So that's a strong mood.
Is he strong?
Read it once in an article that said like Michael Jordan did that once.
He called down and wanted condoms,
brought up once a week and I was,
for whatever reason that came into my mind and I'm like,
just call down and ask
from.
And the dude really hooked it up.
It's awesome.
Then this girl,
she showed me like the sexual light and a,
she still hasn't texted me back so
I really,
I'm looking at is hit it and quit it.
You know,
you want to want to know that.
That's another
thing with guys today.
Like,
um,
I was talking to this,
this,
this producer,
this guy,
one of the guys that was on a [inaudible] name name's Rob Weiss.
He's really funny guy.
And um,
he was telling me like a story of a girl he was with and you know how they did
everything and then you know,
like the next day how you would call,
how you doing,
let's get together again.
And the girl like blew him off in a minute,
go and I'll call you right back.
And he goes,
now I'm sitting there like the fucking girls used to do waiting for the call
back.
That never comes.
You know what I mean?
It's the funniest thing.
This generation of women,
they could go out,
bang a guy all night and then just,
you know,
forget about it.
They see that when the birth control pill came along,
the whole fucking world changed it real.
Now when the Internet came along it changed again.
It cheers incense.
Just the acts like a strange thing that I,
I can't figure out like if you really hit it off with someone,
why not?
Why not stay in touch or whatever.
But uh,
you know,
I can't figure out,
you know her mind.
How quick did you come to be honest,
I'm not going to give the exact amount of time,
but it was,
it was so much fun and we,
you know what,
you are talking a lot about his music.
You know,
they could play one of your songs if they got to that site you could play and
one of the songs up there
if it tell them what to go to.
Okay.
Your one last favor and I said it was all my space last time.
No,
it doesn't matter.
But my space is still the gym.
No,
but,
but the point,
and they're revamping my space anyway,
but I'm just making a comeback.
Yeah.
My space is making a comeback.
If you tell them about my space.com/official la rocks,
that's where we can find the official La rocs cause there was an la rocks,
but then play the song until it,
until they set this up for you.
You got understand when these songs were recorded,
number of,
and Max,
I don't even know if he was 17 yet.
He's on the drums.
And Dylan was how old?
13,
14 if I'm,
Dylan was like 13.
He was 13 years old.
Dylan wrote the music,
the plays,
the lead guitar,
the bass,
the lead vocal,
the words.
So people listening to this,
got to realize this is a 13 year old kid on lead vocal and guitar.
He was only playing guitar about a year and a half.
Wow.
Okay.
And you know,
it,
it just happened as a fluke because I was going to use a,
which song we going to play right in court?
John Junkyard junk.
All.
Alright.
A dumb play.
Uh,
when,
when we went into the studio,
they would just going to lay the music down for my album that I still never put
out.
And Dylan asks,
can I sing it?
This is the night before.
And I go,
well yeah,
sure you could sing.
And I,
I didn't know you could sing.
You know,
I go,
but you know,
I would never put anything on an album that would embarrass you.
So if it doesn't sound right,
we'll just use the music.
So they go in,
they laid the track,
the music track down in one take.
Then Dylan did the baseline and one take,
and then the engineer goes,
you know,
if you want,
cause he's a little kid.
He goes,
you could come back tomorrow and do the vocal.
And he goes,
rock and roll happens at night.
Okay,
so now,
now with that being said,
this is,
you know,
a couple of years ago,
so do the one that's junk yard.
So 13 and how old at this time,
don't say 13.
I'm 17,
13 and 17
rusted and
backing from the,
when
say
for 13 and 17,
this is fucking unbelievable.
Yeah.
You guys,
Alison chains fans.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It sounds it's fucking good,
dude.
Yeah,
that's right.
Great.
That's it.
Okay.
Gets better.
And the smile
big.
Fucking Joe.
No.
Wow.
Great drumming,
man.
You know what else I like?
It's not some boy band bullshit.
This is,
this is adult rock.
Yeah.
They want,
they want it to be like a to ban guns and roses.
Well,
you got talented kids,
man.
That's got to feel it.
Great.
Yeah.
How many songs you've got up there?
I think there's only like three or four on the actual,
what's,
what's on there?
Where,
where are they going to?
If people at home want to listen to this,
if you go to myspace.com/official la raw official la rocks,
what does songs,
what do you dedicate your time to more stand up for that?
Well,
I've really been doing the,
uh,
doing the standup mostly because the band actually broke up.
You and your brother broke up?
Well,
well,
what happened was real short,
when these record companies came at them,
Dylan got a little overwhelmed and I couldn't blame him and I would actually
tell them,
I go,
look,
I'm not Joe Jackson.
I'm not going to force you into stardom.
You know what I mean?
Good for you.
But,
but now he's like back into it and they were actually going to open my special
for me.
That's fucking awesome.
That's gotta be so cool,
man.
Have you kids doing something like that,
you know?
And the reality is regular life sucks.
Having a regular job,
being some fucking dude working in an office.
When you see your dad live in the way he lives and doing what he wants to do and
being free,
it's really not that many other paths for you.
You grew up with it.
You know,
you see it.
It's the greatest way to make a living in the history of the fucking universe.
Creating your own shit.
Put it out there.
People love it.
They come to see you,
they give you money and you're fucking have a great time and you live this life
like the big fat,
stupid party that it's supposed to be.
Well,
you know,
that sounds good.
You know,
you can do it.
he,
he already realizes what it assaults people could be.
So he goes,
I can't wait to become famous so I could just get a house and put a big wall
between me and the rest of the world.
You know,
like when he'll come home,
like from the comedy store at night,
you know,
because of everything he sees that they're,
it's just the funniest way.
Now he puts it to me.
It's weird watching kids,
uh,
like Max being raised.
He's had the internet his whole life too.
There are different kids today,
21 year old.
You are much more mature,
advanced aware than I was when I was 21 when I was 21.
I was a fucking idiot when I first started doing stand up.
I didn't know what the fuck was going on in the world.
I didn't care.
You know,
one of the reasons why I like,
I like dirty jokes cause that's the only shit that I thought it was actually
funny.
You know,
that's all I cared about and it was 21 years old.
What did,
what did I care about?
Cared about?
Like fucking,
you know,
that's what I wanted to do on again,
it's a dirty word and fuck it is a drug.
That's why,
that's why I initially started off like trying to be like a really clean comic
and it just has not really gotten that way because it's,
it's really hard to just be one to be clean.
Now Jerry Seinfeld as a,
I admire him as a man who crafts jokes.
If you go and you listen and he's phenomenal.
Yeah,
he's a craftsman.
I mean he knows how it's pacing his delivery.
His right toe is the best clean comic though my dad always uses a Seinfeld is
ass again is another great example.
Gaffigan is a Goddamn craftsman and he likes doing that kind of comedy.
You hang out and talk to the guy.
That's how he talks.
But to me,
you know what's always been the funniest to me is people just get fucking crazy.
I don't,
I don't want to go see,
I love comedy period.
I mean,
I'll go to see a clean comic if he's really funny.
I would love to go see Gaffigan or something like that.
But if I,
if I had my choice,
I see some people live in it.
We're in a dirty world.
We live in reality with a lot of dirty things going on.
So if you're on stage as a comic,
you know,
our whole job is commentary on the world,
you know?
Yeah.
And you need to address every unturned rock and it's,
and it's like to be a new comic in the year 2012 you know,
Seinfeld even came up in the early eighties you know,
it seems like it might've been a little easier to be green or at that time Queen
Shit's done,
son.
The Internet came along once goats,
he was around when I saw people calling apart their asshole with a wedding ring
in your hand.
You ever see that picture?
Of course you have.
How about tough girl.
You ever see top girl,
the girl when the ass up in the air,
a fountain spray of diarrhea is splattering on her face.
She has a cheesecloth over it.
I can't.
I can't look at those things.
It's incredible.
One of it.
Have you seen the MR hands now?
Haven't seen a lot.
I've heard of a lot of [inaudible].
Mr Hands,
the guy that gets fucked to death by a horse,
he was a guy.
They started,
they changed the law in Washington state about this guy.
They made a documentary about it called zoo.
Apparently for the longest tie,
Washington state,
it was legal to have sex with animals so people would fly to Washington state
and move in and make farms together and have sex and make videos.
Oh,
ridiculous shit.
Did see that video?
It's insane.
None of this was around when and when your dad was around when he was young and
this was around when I was your age.
You were growing up in a,
in an area of exposure,
a different world than anything that I saw when I was 21 legal.
It's going to be interesting with animals.
It's not any more.
They changed it.
It was just an old law that,
you know,
it was on the books forever.
And so they,
they were,
they were found this loophole.
It's actually like a,
uh,
clinical psychological disorder.
It's called zoophilia or Washington.
Like if you ask somebody like you seeing anybody,
yeah,
I'm living with a ferret.
Right.
They were into horses.
They weren't a things get fucking them.
The guy had a perforated colon bled out and they filthy is,
I get on stage and I get filthy,
you know,
uh,
like that's the kind of stuff I can't even look at.
Do you,
would you go on the Internet and fuck around and let go to message boards and
no,
nothing.
I don't,
you know,
and I,
and I even,
you know,
cause I knew they grew up with the,
the computer generation that even when they were kids,
I would say like,
look,
I know what's out there.
You know,
I could go though.
The one good thing about having me as a father,
as you know,
you could talk to me about anything.
You know,
you don't
have to watch your language if you're talking about a girl or you know,
right.
You know,
you could,
you could talk straight to me.
Just tell me straight out and how it is.
And I would always tell my kids,
do yourselves a favor.
Stay away from,
from the porno on the Internet.
I go,
you're going to grow up.
You're going to start dating girls.
You don't want your mind twisted and bent that badly too late day.
Nope.
Too late.
No,
but,
but it's the truth.
And you know,
Max was honest enough at that time,
he had a friend that went to it a few times and so we'll just stay away from,
this is also when I was like 12,
but what,
that's what I'm saying,
that's the age where like,
you know,
like you could see a thing like,
uh,
some chick blow in a horse and think,
oh,
that's what you supposed to do.
You know,
kids don't get it.
You know what I mean?
Earlier,
no,
no one fucking sick in the head.
Especially like early exposure to like really graphic sexual images like video
and porn.
It probably can be good for again,
it's probably not.
No,
it's shit.
It's impossible for to go hardcore type Shit,
you know.
And that guy is,
he's one of,
he's the only one of the only guys in recent memory that has been arrested for
um,
obscenity.
They took them to chick that took them a trial in Florida.
Has his videos are so obscene that they took this guy to trial in one state
because they knew that you can get them if they went in for,
to has very strict obscenity laws.
That's how they got two live crew in Florida.
I remember that shit when they got arrested.
Did you ever do an issue in Florida?
Did you ever have any the in Florida,
I had it in Cleveland though,
the entire dress and I'll never forget,
you know,
cause management,
they try to keep you out of it.
And I come into my dressing room and uh,
well there's a problem,
you know,
and I'm like,
what's the,
does a,
you know,
a,
an arena or in Cleveland and all of a sudden the dressing room is flooded with
cops,
you know,
telling me if anybody complains,
anybody you're going to jail.
And I was like,
what year are we living hauling?
Oh shucks,
I'll tell you what.
You tell me what words you don't want me to say.
As long as I step on that stage,
I get my check.
I'll do five fucking minutes.
I don't care.
I got it.
But who would complain that it's buying a dice ticket cheeses and obviously
hadn't got to jail.
What year was this?
This was probably around 93.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
I went through some stuff that's,
you know,
with a three in Canada,
where they were really detain you on the bus and really go through everything.
And I'm go,
look,
we're not druggies on this bus with just doing comedy shows.
It's not what I do.
They can be rough when you crossed the border to Montreal.
But I've been lucky they mailed to take a walk in the snow that I had to take a
nap afterwards.
It was so hard and it was like four in the morning and means you walk in the
snow all the way to this fucking thing with our office was and all of us on the
bus.
You know,
I traveled with a band,
they traveled with my guys.
It's why Canada is so nice.
They have a zero douche bag rule.
If you're even remotely Douche.
Baggish at the,
the uh,
the border patrol that I get the fuck Outta here man.
If you have a Dui,
get the fuck outta here.
If you have an assault,
get the fuck out.
You get a Dui,
you can't go to Canada.
Why can this offer you can never go too.
It's why Canada is so awesome.
They want it.
They won't let in any American Douche bags is a,
I mean there's,
there's a fucking a smart thing to that,
you know,
you can really think about what you do.
You live in Canada,
you like a bunch of Nice people and this frozen country that's connected to the
craziest fucking savages that have ever existed are the face of the planet.
There's no,
no crazier country.
If you look at like total impact on the world than America,
Fuck Rome,
Rome can suck my dick.
We're in 140 different countries with fucking nuclear arms.
We've got bombs and tanks and Jetson,
drones,
everybody should sit the fuck down and Kay.
So Canada is like above us and every now and then one of us is running from the
law and they try to get into Canada.
So of course they'd have to have like really fucking strict laws,
any criminal tendencies and conditioners.
They saw that coming a long time ago and they were like,
Eh,
we got to shut it down.
I shut her.
Appreciate it.
I,
that's why I have such a great time up in Canada because they do that.
They're so stringent.
It is great.
The editor Canada really is awesome.
It's amazing.
I'm at the River Creek Casino in June.
You're going to,
you're going to love that place.
Yeah,
I've been to a bunch of times.
I got them right here for you.
Uh,
so next Wednesday a dice will be at Westbury music fair and that is in Long
Island.
We're in Long Island,
Westbury,
Westbury.
Doug.
That's next Wednesday.
And then Friday and Saturday he said the joker's wild in new haven,
Connecticut.
My old stomping club.
I used to do that club,
but when I lived in new Rochelle and that should be a lot of fun.
And then a next Sunday,
this is the big one.
Asbury Park,
New Jersey.
Bamboozle.
And who you working with there?
Well,
I'm going on right before Bon Jovi.
Oh Shit.
Do my show and then he'll do it.
I don't know what stage I'm on,
but my show is the one right before I met Bon Jovi.
And uh,
he was,
uh,
I've met him a couple times.
I opened for them once in Queens,
did this MTV theater in the round.
They were very nice guys and I always had to,
you know,
pin it up.
I'm just real friendly guys.
But then I read this thing with him and his wife.
They own a restaurant and they have a restaurant where the people that go to the
restaurant pay whatever they can afford to pay.
So instead of like it'd be an a soup kitchen,
people can go with dignity and just pay whatever little money they have for it
for a nice meal and some they're like really compassionate,
nice people.
I've heard about that.
That's a wild concept.
That's a beautiful concept.
That's,
it's a beautiful thing that they do,
especially in this fucked up economy.
So props to Bon Jovi and you'll be here with him.
That's next Sunday.
Asbury Park,
New Jersey at bamboozle.
That should be fucking crazy,
dude.
Thank you very much.
It's been an honor for me as a comic.
Like I said,
when I came up,
man,
you were one of the guys that I really looked up to,
and so to have you on the podcast,
it's like a crazy experience for me.
Thanks.
Thanks again for back in the day,
given me advice.
And you really didn't,
you were the reason why I decided to go on the road because I listened to him
and I was like,
yeah,
why don't I go on the road?
It may be a better comic too.
You know,
all the d just going up at the store,
only then Kinda make you monster.
You can become that.
You could get sucked into it's demonic spell if you ever become a real fucking
creep.
Uh,
thank you everybody for tuning into the podcast and we will see you next week.
We've got a lot of show coming up next week.
Next week we've got Michael Rupert,
he's going to be here on Tuesday and chill sun and the day before on Monday.
And then,
uh,
Shane Smith will be the week after that.
We got a lot of shit going on.
A lot of,
a lot of new people that I'm,
uh,
putting in where John Anthony West and I are exchanging emails.
So we're gonna be doing that as well too,
which I'm fucking super psyched about.
Ah,
thanks to the flashlight for sponsoring us a always our first sponsor when
nobody would take it seriously.
They've been there from the beginning and they're,
they're,
they're solid and it's a fucking solid product as well.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight.
Enter in the code name Rogan and save yourself 15% and thank you to [inaudible]
dot com that's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and various nootropics like shroom tech,
sport and trim,
tech,
immune and five HTP.
Enhanced new mood.
Check that shit out and 100% money back guarantee on the first 30 pills you
order.
You don't even have to resell this stuff back to us to say it sucks and you get
your money back.
You use the code name Rogan,
save yourself 10% on any and all orders.
All right,
you dirty bitches.
This is the end of this show,
but it is Friday and it's seven o'clock in about two hours.
Yeah,
two hours.
We will be doing the ice house chronicles and that takes place right here at the
Ice House in Pasadena.
You can only listen to it on desk won.
So subscribe to the desk squad on iTunes or you can watch it on my Ustream page
tonight.
This one here,
Joe Rogan and Ustream.
Dot.
TV Ford Slash Joe Rogan.
Hey Joe,
I got tee shirts on sale today and that squat tee shirts.
Pretty bad ass.
Where can they get these death squad.tv.
Dot TV click on desk watch shop and their stickers and shirts.
Yeah.
And uh,
for all you rumor mongering cunt faces out there that thought for some reason
because me and Brian did a couple of podcast away from each other.
I wasn't with my little snuggle bunny did this some sort of bridge or a gap
between us.
This is not true.
And he is my friend and Brian will always be on the Joe Rogan experience as long
as he wants to,
unless he gets really fucking crazy.
Blows a fuse or gets aids.
All right,
that's it.
See you soon.
You dirty bitches.
Icehouse chronicles nine o'clock followed dice clay,
the real dice clay on Twitter and anything else,
Dyson.
I'm all good and follow.
Matt was great.
Beautiful.
Thank you sir.
Appreciate it.
And Fall Max was Max's.
I met Max,
D,
U,
Z,
z comedy Max,
d,
u,
z.
Z comedy.
That's it.
Follow Max.
Fall dice.
Fall red band,
red ban.
Love you.
Dirty bitches.
We'll see you soon.
All right.